I'm live!
Hello everybody!
I have two people here with me today for the Nessie Cup Tournament!
Would you guys like to introduce yourselves?
This is going to be my forever team for today.
Oh wait, sorry, they can't hear you.
My description is weird.
It's okay, I'll listen to your creepy names.
You can go now.
Now I'm scared.
Oh wait.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
Hi, I'm Himi, or Himalayas, but call me Himi.
Happy to be here.
Hey, Senox, you're next!
Hi, my name is Senox.
I play competitive 8-packs.
I don't know, that's about it.
He's the guy that looks like Gibraltar IRL.
For the game.
For those who are wondering, we've talked about him before.
What team are we?
Team 6?
Yeah, we're Team 6.
Wait, we're IRL.
We got Countdown.
We got Countdown?
Not at all.
Wait, that's pretty good.
Pretty good.
We were discussing strats earlier.
Is the challenge public yet?
Or is it still only on stream?
I had the thing open on my stream.
Oh, okay.
I'm just gonna put it on my... Oh my god, I can put images on my stream now.
I wasn't able to in the past.
But yeah, we were discussing our challenges, what we're doing and stuff.
So...
Have we decided who's gonna be doing what yet?
Um...
You gonna put him again?
Nah, I mean...
For the most part, I think the only individual ones that matter is the FOV and no attachments.
Yeah, so...
But hey, everybody can do whatever.
You just pick up like a sniper, you just do whatever.
So like, we delegated Heemi to be the 90 FOV, cause she's not streaming.
So chat... she doesn't have chat to go through 90 FOV.
And other than that, we tried to decide who's gonna do the no attachments and the P20 gun.
Any volunteers?
Who's playing Wraith?
Who's gonna get the kidnap off?
I think so.
I think Senox is doing the Wraith thing, right?
Oh, beautiful.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, there's also... wait, there's a comp challenge in here too.
Yeah, it's Valkyrie Caustic.
Yeah, but it's just one point.
Because it's like, either you do the Wraith or you do... you get like one point off of the comp.
How am I... what are they... there's only one Wraith one also, right?
Yeah, there's only one Wraith, so it's either one or the other.
I feel like... I think Senox is right.
We should probably just do like our own comp because like... for the ammo and shield cells and all that.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Hold on, I'm being cringe.
I'm getting a loop off.
That's not good.
I think it's... PY's are changing every game, right?
I don't think so.
Well, it's different.
I think maybe World's Edge we get like countdown the entire time and then Stormpoint we get like a different... obviously different POI.
I mean, we could always ask Tempo.
Also chat, how's the volume for everybody?
I hate audio balancing.
Oh guys, this is not bingo.
It's basically whoever does the most challenges per game or win the game gets like money.
Gets like a thousand five hundred per team.
So it's not bingo, it's just whoever does the most challenges.
Oh, he needs a little low.
Okay, let me boost up Hini's volume.
Boop.
Test.
Can you screen... like can you...
Get up your mic for us.
Wait, I think it's good.
Cause I don't know.
Okay, yeah, yeah, wait, I think you're good.
I think you're good.
Test.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, we're not countdown.
Don't you carry?
We're tree.
We're not... we're tree?
The map said team six countdown.
But we're team six.
Wait, who has countdown?
Wait, team two has countdown.
Wait, what?
Wait, Doop is a bastard.
Guy stole our POI.
I mean, tree, tree's fine.
Wait, how... how the fuck did...
Numbers don't matter.
Oh my gosh, how do you buy the new loop path?
Rigged!
I mean, tree is... tree's really easy.
I know, I like it.
I like tree, honestly.
It's good for the game.
Are we doing rampart, Loba, raids still?
Yes, I think so.
Okay.
What are we using the rampart for?
Damage?
We're just doing it for knocking people to damage.
We could just drop rampart for like, watson or something.
Because meds might be a problem.
I mean, I could do...
It's preference whoever's playing that character.
Uh...
I can do... I can do any of them.
Watson, caustic, or rampart.
So it really depends on which is the best one.
I mean, caustic's like hard, meta, and uncom, but...
I don't know how competitive this is gonna be.
I think if... I mean...
I think it's gonna be sweaty.
I feel like... I mean...
Not gonna lie, but some teams are very imbalanced.
Yeah, some of the teams are really imbalanced.
I played like... I streamed Apex once last week, so...
So these teams are pretty imbalanced.
We're playing the game on easy mode.
We're sitting center zone.
Mimi, I nominate you to do no attachments.
Okay.
On my d20?
You're supposed to fight back!
You're not just supposed to accept it!
Hell nah, Dokie.
That's some bullsh...
I don't think you are.
I can't believe you would do this.
I've just met you, but you should do the no attachments.
Since you think you know everything.
Are you an IGL?
Senox, who should do it?
No, Senox, you pick!
You're the IGL.
Who's worse?
Realistically, who's worse?
If we wanna be real.
What's your rating?
If you want me to choose, that's what I'm saying.
What's your rank, Mimi?
Unfortunately, who is worse?
I am not the IGL.
It's definitely one of y'all.
Yes, IGL is telling us who is the worst player out of the two of us, Mimi.
What's your rank?
Oh, I'm like diamond-ish?
I don't know.
Higher rank than me.
Whoa!
Not right now!
Oh my gosh, currently?
Today?
Yeah, currently today.
What's your rank today?
No, I'm like...
What am I?
Gold?
Oh, thank god, I'm plat right now.
Okay, Mimi, you can tell.
Evil.
Oh, no, shut up.
I'm plat right now, so...
You're goaded, so you're the actual...
The lowest ranked... the lowest ranked member should play the no attachments in P20.
Yeah, there we go.
There we go.
We figured it out.
What's your rank, Senox?
Yeah, what's your rank, Senox?
I got Mastiffs when the season came out.
Or I got Predator when the season came out and I haven't played it since.
Oh.
So you are a Master?
So he's Masters.
Probably Masters.
Yeah, so he's still the highest rank.
Highest rank IGL.
It's the rule.
I sent you the thing.
It's pretty easy.
It's Shriek.
Whoever's on beacon character, you just loot mid and hit beacon.
Okay.
Someone else hits Logram.
Someone else hits the other side.
My thing...
Watson, Rampart, or Caustic?
IGL.
It's up to me.
Whichever one you want to play.
I don't think it matters.
I mean, Rampart, we could use it to get more...
more sniper knocks and like overall damage.
Caustic would just be better for actually winning games.
Yeah, but like we're not here to win games.
True.
We're here to do challenges.
Does Watson do anything for any of these?
An Arcstar stick?
You could turn all your nades into Arcstars.
Um...
Alright.
Okay, so...
I guess it's all RNG on how many meds we get, honestly.
Okay.
I'll just pick up Rampart then.
If there's... or...
I'll just pick up Rampart then just for the damage padding.
If we're doing... I mean, it'll be good for snipers if we're doing damage padding.
Yeah.
Use your ult three times.
What... how do I... oh wait, Loba.
That'll be fast for Loba.
W.
Yeah.
I feel like we should do the Evo Harvester like instantly.
Just travel... travel to all the Evo Harvesters.
Yeah, we can just hit them on the way.
We can hit them on the way.
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess it all just depends where the zone is.
Cause if it's across the map, we could just play like... you know what I mean?
It just depends where the zone is.
We'll have to use our evac towers.
Our three evac towers.
Yeah.
Oh, and we have a Loba to get those Eva towers.
Oh my god.
We can use three evacs at the same time.
We're thinking...
We were supposed to start our game like nine minutes ago.
We're the...
Who is not here?
Wait, girl's not here.
Girl, the host isn't here in the lobby.
I mean in my mic.
Actually, I think we'll play Wattson.
Oh shit, nevermind.
If a lot of the people are playing Gibby Kossack for the challenge, we're like actually gonna get took by Gibby Kossack out without Wattson.
Yeah.
That is... that is so smart.
I nominate Doki to play Wattson.
Oh my god.
That's good cause I was gonna nominate myself anyway.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Yeah, I can do Wattson.
I used to play her.
She's so cute.
I love her.
Where is girl?
Girl, where are you?
You're the host.
Alright, I muted my mic.
I'm so anxious.
They're so serious.
Bro, they're like... they're like metachronistic.
I wanted to do her crafting earlier before I started this stream.
I was just like, hey!
The anxiety.
You know, I found out that wasn't a th- okay, by participating, we each get like $500.
I thought we'd get $1,500.
I was like, fuck yeah!
I don't care how well we do, we get a thousand five hundred dollars each.
And then I realized I can't read and it actually says every team gets a thousand five hundred so I get five hundred dollars I get five hundred for participating and just being there which is great because that means if I cuz there's three tournaments So that means if I sign up for all three Technically I can get a thousand five hundred
It's still better than nothing!
Exactly!
It's still better than being a professional player!
Sorry, that's a low blow.
That's a low blow!
It's still better!
I still earn more than a regular professional player!
So...
So that's all that matters!
That's all that matters!
Oh my god.
Anyway...
Yeah, people are very... I was like... when I... okay...
I remember I saw the teams and I was like, oh shit, this is like...
Some of these teams are very, very, like... like... really good.
And then, I was like, maybe the minigames are like actual minigames, you know?
Like, no punches, or like no weapons.
Punch-outs, stuff like that.
And I was like, wait, you actually have to play the game?
And I was just like...
I was like, what do you mean?
What... why do some teams have two Preds?
I'm not Pred... guys, guys, I'm washed.
I mean like, two current Preds!
Sorry, let me be more specific.
Two current Preds!
I was like, what the fuck?
The last time I streamed Apex was last week!
Anyway, oh, let me know!
Thank you for the 50 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, anyway, so I'm just like, folk, they were like, let's try and win!
And I was like, win?
Alright, let's just spray this on this new Skyhooker Shrouds, because of my winning streak.
Okay.
Yay, we're starting!
Alright, I got this.
I got Watson picked out.
Wait, where is she?
We all just...
get a bunch of shield cells together, we can make a heart instantly.
How big does that heart need to be?
I don't think it has to be that big, I think it just needs to be a heart.
I think we just...
Arguably a heart.
I think just one person can just make the heart, and then we're good to go.
I've never made a shield cell heart, have you?
Oh, I can do it!
I can do it.
Good ship and beacon?
Wait...
Wait, we got beacon?
Fuck yeah.
Wait, I land in the middle, right?
Yeah, I can land on the front side.
Alright.
We're gonna be doing the no loot challenge.
We just gotta get the zone and lobo loot.
What's the no loot challenge?
We just don't get loot because we're landing straight.
That's fine, we have lobo, we can just pick the loot up.
Literally, I just pulled up the...
Oh, like the actual challenge?
And I was like, wait, what?
I don't remember how the loot pack was, but I know I was in the middle.
You just loot all of mid and then you can hit beacon whenever.
Yay, okay.
Actually, you can land on the beacon and hit it.
Can you still double hit beacons?
I forgot about that.
Oh my god, okay, hang on.
FOV.
Oh yeah, FOV 90, no attachments.
Remember, zero attachments.
Okay.
Ooh, we gotta run double heavy.
It's actually not that bad.
Yeah, it's just bad on stream.
It just looks terrible.
I need a P20.
No P20s on my side.
Where is the zone out yet?
I have a blue bag, give me nades.
Alright.
I have a blue bag too.
Oh my god, I literally feel like I'm in a fishbowl.
If you're doing sniper, here it is.
I'm gonna scan.
We can go.
We should go, we should go.
Oh my god, skull piercer.
I'm gonna loot this build and then dip.
Alright, I only found two stacks of shield cells.
That's really neat.
I didn't get shit, to be honest.
I have a lot of names.
Do we get any evacs?
We have one evac.
Let's try to hit this balloon and pray we don't die hitting it.
I feel like, yeah, we shouldn't use any evacs yet.
We won't have to just use one to get in the zone.
No, how are you evacs?
I have my ult, should I drop it?
Nah, nah, nah, I won't use it.
I mean, just drop it now, cause you recharged it fast.
We just need to use it three times, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, just drop it now, do it.
Okay, I'll go.
Yeah, and we'll just look at it for like one second.
I'm gonna loot an ulti.
I'm gonna grab a shield cell.
Oh, beautiful.
How badly I want this.
And I'll get the arch-stars too.
I have two, four, I have five nades already.
How many do you guys have?
Fly!
My, almost my whole bottom row is nades.
Oh, wait, we can combine our nades.
Land on this roof.
Actually, I can't.
Wait, isn't there people there?
Not yet.
They're on me.
Go back, go back, go back over here.
Run back over here.
I'm gonna Q.
Just go.
Oh, I might be dead.
We can craft if we die.
Alright, we're fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Come inside, run inside.
Run deep to the tunnel.
Alright.
They're aping us, hard aping us.
This guy's on Revenant.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Which way, left or right?
Oh, right.
You might have to hold them here.
They're literally here.
They're here.
Oh, yeah, I'm dead.
I didn't know it was left or right.
Cracked off.
You're pushing, hard pushing.
Hard aping, hard aping.
I'm not gonna lie.
Just run, Sylas.
Run!
I did not hear them climb up there.
If you're gonna die, name yourself.
If you're gonna die, at least kill yourself with names.
Oh, wait, yeah, I'm actually gonna kill myself with names.
Kill yourself with names or you're gonna die.
Okay, I mean, we technically did accomplish some of these challenges.
Bro, this Revenant character is OP.
I needed myself, I needed myself, I needed myself.
We got that!
That's all you needed.
Amazing.
It's okay, we got like, okay, I don't think we won this game.
I don't think we got this game's challenge.
I had 90 FOV and I had, I didn't get a knock with the P20.
I just had the P20 for no reason, but I had no attachments.
Hey, that's two challenges right there.
Two points for me, yeah.
Yeah, that's two new points.
I should have like just ran to the right.
Shouldn't have walked back to you guys.
I was confused too.
I didn't know if we were going left or right.
I was just like...
I'm not gonna lie.
I heard the revenant ult and the jump and we were just dead.
No, we split up.
One of us could have lived.
I just didn't know which way to go.
It's okay, we got three challenges, even though I don't think those three challenges...
We were not last!
We got 19th place.
Why did somebody die before us?
Yeah, I don't know.
I guess like losers and they die before us.
Imagine dying first, Hop.
I know, right?
Can you be...
I'm not gonna lie.
It's okay.
It's not me.
We didn't die first.
Imagine dying first.
Wait, was there no sound?
What do you mean guys?
There were totally...
That was totally sound.
Okay, let me just harass tempo into posting game two.
On the game two list.
Oh yeah, after the game ends, have one player.
I mean...
We could technically post our stuff now.
Yeah, we could.
Please be accurate.
We will be going over the VODs, thanks.
Oh, they can't go after my VODs.
I have no replay.
I don't have permissions yet, so maybe they open it up at the end of the game.
That makes sense.
Poor Temple.
He can't look at my VOD.
He has to wait until my stream's over.
And turn down Senox.
Actually, I just coin flipped the game on them red setting, but they didn't have a beacon character.
I'm just glad that I don't have to play a 90 FOV.
Well, what if they have 90 FOV again in the card?
Doubt it.
They might though.
They might.
I really do feel like...
I don't know.
They might get harder or they might change the guns that you have to get Nox with.
I'm pretty sure they'll change the comps and stuff too.
Yeah, I think the comp one will change every game and then the guns will change.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
I'm pretty sure.
It's okay.
This was just warm up.
This was warm up here.
And we sort of landed on them, to be fair.
Oh yeah, I know.
I was actually just assuming they'd be gone because they're landing next to Enzo, but they just weren't playing a beacon character.
I know.
That was pretty unlucky.
It's okay.
If this team wins, then we technically won.
We would've won the game.
Yeah, technically we won the game because we got killed by the winners.
So, we would have lived regardless.
I'm gonna message Tempo and be like, let me see game two.
Let me see the game two list so we can Metacraft.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Tempo, show me game two.
Not that.
Aw, Doki, I think I have some people from your community following you on Twitter.
Huh.
Oh, that's nice.
Wait!
Tempo's making the card in between games?
He's done it!
He doesn't even... Oh, that's gonna take...
No one's in game two!
Okay, we should give him ideas.
We should give him ideas.
He was like, I don't even know.
I'm literally making the card right now.
Okay.
One of the challenges could be have a fat ass.
So, check.
I got y'all covered.
Which that means just play Loba.
Just play Loba.
Okay, chat, we can like influence Tempo.
He'll do what I'll say.
Like in pieces.
Um...
I mean, honestly, some fuse action could be funny.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
One of the cards should be... One of the challenges should be play fuse.
Oh, knockout with punch!
Yes!
Yes.
Punch him out.
Um...
I've got ten million things open and going out.
Bro, Tempo has seven monitors?
Holy sh... Wait.
Can I show this on stream?
Mana's not...
Oh my god!
Oh wait, this team's dying.
Oh, they're kind of living though.
This Revenant is cooking.
Like, who is this?
Who is this?
That's dropped.
Oh my god, Tempo has fucking seven mon... He has a laptop open...
To a finisher on them Rev.
On the side.
Look, the drop is a serious person.
The monitor is kind of crazy.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yes!
It's sick!
Oh my god!
He has a second computer monitor on the side.
Like a second computer.
I'm sorry, Tempo.
If you're watching this and you didn't want me to leak that...
Oh, he can let me... He said I can show it!
Guys, look at his fucking setup.
It's actually crazy.
Oh my god!
How...
That's like too... That's like sensor overload for me.
Jesus Christ.
Look at this, guys.
Oh... It's... Oh...
Look at this, seven fucking monitors.
xQc was right.
How do you...
That is like... Like, three monitors is already too much for me.
Seven mon... Two m... Two mouse, two keyboards.
Actually, three mouse, four keyboards, seven mon... Seven monitors, one PC, a camera, a mic.
My god.
He had to like check... He had to like check to make sure there was nothing confidential.
He needs to go further beyond.
Five cats.
Six consoles.
Oh my god.
This is... This is like... He organized this tournament, but...
By the way, guys.
Like, you need to have at least seven monitors to be able to organize this tournament.
That's actually crazy.
That's a lot of PC.
Zero wall... It's okay, guys.
I can like peer pressure him to buy Doki merch.
And then he can put...
Little acrobat.
He's thinking with the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
By the way, I muted myself.
I feel like... I don't want to like...
Bother them with the shit I say.
I can peer pressure him to buy Doki merch and put that...
Wait, let me message that.
If... If I send... Okay, if you... You should buy my merch...
To decorate your wall.
It's so... It's so empty.
And then, he...
And then, it's like... it's like free... Okay, it's not free advertising because like he's...
He has to pay for my merch.
But it's like, it's... Oh, it is free advertising for me!
Because he's the one that spent money.
So it's technically free advertising for me.
Okay... I should like, let you guys actually watch the game.
Not look at, not look at Tempo's face.
I'm so happy that I got this fucking setup.
All these monitors and zero doki merch.
It's a free win-win!
Exactly!
Exactly.
So anytime...
Anytime someone comes in, he's like TSM's manager.
So like, I might be able to get TSM fans to buy my merch!
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but I'm playing the game This Is Me right now.
This Is Me right now.
No, don't die!
You have to win!
So it technically means we died to the champion!
You guys can't die!
You guys as in me.
I can't die.
God, I'm so good at this game.
Holy shit.
Seven kills already.
Number one revved me.
You can call me number one Pred.
No!
Dropped!
I mean doki!
Don't die!
You have to live!
No!
I died!
It's okay.
It's just...
Guys, just so you guys know.
That was not me.
I would never play like that.
Played.
It's okay.
This is actually me.
It was a little spectator bug that happened.
So I am...
Wait, who is on my team?
Who is on my team?
Okay.
That is...
I'm DZ.
DZ0 is like...
Doki...
Doki's...
Bird 0.
Doki's 0 bird.
Wait, what is he playing right now?
Is he on Bangalore?
No, he's on...
Okay, am I on Bangalore?
I'm on Bangalore.
Doki's...
Doki's 0 bird.
There we go.
I always knew... I know!
The thing is, Doki is universal.
I can be from any country.
So like, today I'm in Australia.
Today I'm on Australia.
I can do whatever I want.
It will be funny if we actually did influence Tempos game 2 bingo.
Or not bingo.
What is it called?
Uh...
Like, challenge sheet.
It feels like...
You made this.
I made this.
You are 0?
I'm 0.
Australian Doki.
I mean, I'm technically like...
I'm like halfway there.
I swear a lot.
They say... I don't say that.
That is sadly not in my... Is it sadly not in... That is not in my natural vocabulary.
You hesitated.
Oh, what was I gonna say?
You'll never know.
You'll never... They say what?
I don't know.
What would they be saying?
So, do we keep our POI?
Oh, no.
It changes.
Wait, it changes?
Aw, okay.
Thankfully.
Oh, I mean, I'm... I didn't like tree anyway.
I didn't like tree anyway.
Drop the bomb, mate.
You can't say I have the pass!
I'm only...
I only have Australian!
You can say can't.
Yeah.
I can't say that word.
What?
I can't do that!
What do you mean?
I can't understand what you're talking about.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, half a pass.
Half the word.
Oh, my God.
Who's gonna win?
I like how nobody's doing the... the... We should have done the Valkyrie thing.
We could have got one more.
Whoa!
I died.
Doki zero bird!
How could you?
You're supposed to be the champion!
How could you do this?
All right, who's in this team?
Oh, my God.
Okay, wait.
Who's... Okay.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Is that Sykes?
Okay, they're on the same team.
It's technically the same thing.
It's now Doki... Doki's Sykes bird.
They're on the same team.
It's the same thing.
I'm on the same team.
13 kills.
Because he's a pro player!
He's a controller player!
The only thing we were missing was a controller player.
Okay?
What do you want us to do?
We're all in MM... Wait, is it Sunox controller or MMK?
Let me look at the input real fast.
I just don't remember.
Okay.
They're also MMK!
Look!
I'm sorry!
We were nerfed so hard!
Okay?
We were... We were nerfed so hard!
We're all full MMK players!
What were we supposed to do?
We were all MMK!
Movement can't save us!
Oh, why is that... Oh, that's like the Pathfinder thingy, right?
Oh my god, where are they?
That poor Gibraltar is just floating in the...
That poor Caustic that was in the middle of nowhere.
What the fuck?
I'm the content creator!
What do you mean?
Each team has three people.
An Apex streamer.
A pro player.
And the content creator.
I am the content creator!
You cannot put all the expectations on me!
We should be putting all the expectations on the pro player.
If we are blaming anybody, it's definitely not me!
Look, I am the content creator.
I want to have Tempo finish this fucking bingo card.
No, I'm gonna blame you.
I'm not two things!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
I put myself in the content creator role!
I put myself in the content creator.
There's no coping here.
Alright, let's see.
Did he finish the list?
I don't think he did.
I'd be so surprised.
How many challenges did we complete?
Uh...
I mean...
I'm pretty sure it has...
Was it just three?
I don't think we did, no.
Not a lot.
We died instantly.
Yeah, but we did so many things, though.
No, we really didn't, though.
We didn't have chance.
Um, I had...
We had half a V, then no attachments, and then the nade, right?
That's it.
Was it really that?
What was the nade?
Okay, yeah, it was three.
Okay, three.
It's okay.
The other people did three as well.
We're not last in the challenges either.
Who the fuck did A?
That's insane.
Oh my god.
Zero got ten.
They got zero?
Wait, they got zero!
At least we didn't get zero.
Not last!
We're not zero!
They might be the team that died last, too.
Or died first.
If they got zero, that is actually unfortunate.
Guys, I just need you guys to know, chat.
Three is the average.
There's like six other people with three.
We're not alone.
Guys, we got the average!
We got it!
I have to like really think about this.
And honestly, like...
We...
If we would have maybe played slower, we maybe would have had more time to finish some of these like little easy ones.
I don't know.
Yeah, we could have got their little heart.
Our little heart and then we could have been a four.
Yeah, like even before we left the POI, like we could have did the fucking...
We could just not play hard zone then.
Because if we're playing hard zone, we have to go center zone.
But if we die early, we just get zeroed in.
Let's just... yeah, let's just do all the easy stuff in our POI and then move on.
I'm done.
I wonder what Tempo figured out in between games.
Yeah, I hope he actually changes the challenges.
Oh no, he is.
He's like doing them in between games.
Alright, we just do all the ones we can do instantly without having to do any work.
And then we just get the other ones out.
And we just... if we do good in the game, do the other ones.
I'm done.
Yeah, yeah, just get the easy ones out.
Alright, we just have like...
Like some of the challenges done then zero.
Like that poor man over there.
Chat, do not worry.
I will not call out the person that got zero.
You might be able to find out on girls stream yourself.
If you really want to know.
You won't find out on my stream.
I am muted.
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips bacon.
Thank you, thank you.
What?
I'm not gonna call anybody out.
Wait, so is it whoever completes the most challenges over all six games?
Or is it just whoever completes it for that game?
For that game.
Okay, so...
But the team that completes the most challenges overall goes to the finals.
You get the money...
How many teams get to go to the finals?
Two teams.
Two teams that completes the most challenges overall gets to go to the finals.
But like you get to win a thousand five hundred.
For the most challenges completed per game.
You get to win a thousand five hundred for winning first place.
Or a thousand five hundred for completing the most challenges.
Oh okay, I'm looking at it right now.
Six teams make finals off of challenges.
One per game and then...
Two individual players with most kills.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's either...
So like finals is just dependent on challenges.
Oh yeah, we actually just need to spam challenges.
Yeah.
One game and just get infinite.
We just do the bare minimum ones we can do.
And then if we have a good game we just crank it out like ten.
Yeah, exactly.
Do we do the same comp?
Or do we...
Should we play the comp that...
I don't know.
I want to see what the challenges are.
I want to see what he changes.
Because if we're not playing...
If we're not rotating then we shouldn't put that comp.
What?
Finals?
Okay.
I'll tell you guys...
I just have to play the comp that has a challenge for playing the actual comp.
Because it's just a free challenge.
Basically.
It is basically like whichever...
There's three tournaments.
There's four tournaments.
But I can't count.
So there's three tournaments that are like the qualifying tournaments.
I should sign up for next week too.
I like didn't sign up for next week.
But if I'd be like, Temple, can I join next week?
Maybe he'll be like, Okay.
Anyway.
At least sign up for like two.
But you can sign up for three.
Anyway.
So there's three tournaments.
And...
And they're each like invitational.
And so basically...
The team that wins the most challenges in each tournament goes towards the finals.
And the finals...
So like the finals will be composed of all the teams that are like the best of each individual tournament.
Each individual tournament is different.
The second one...
The reason why I didn't sign up for the second one was because the second one was actually more reliant on like...
FPS skills.
But I didn't realize this tournament...
I thought the mini games...
What I mean...
In mini games is like hide and seek and stuff like that.
You're not actually like playing...
Everyone's asking for the challenge.
Trying hard and stuff like that.
But now I realize...
Oh shit.
This is actually low key try hard.
So I might as well sign up for the second one as well.
Maybe ahead of time.
Sorry.
I have to listen to what they're saying.
Anyway.
I didn't realize.
Okay.
So now...
Now I'm like, Oh shit.
I might as well sign up for the second one.
Maybe.
Cause the first one is basically like the second one and I already got that out of the way.
So I might as well sign up for the second one also cause the second one is also like...
Like shooting your gun.
So...
I thought...
You know...
I thought there would be like punching, boxing, stuff like that.
Cause it says mini games.
But I didn't realize that what they meant was a bingo charge.
Haha.
Anyway...
Anyway, as I was saying...
So, it's basically whichever team completes the most challenges...
and also whichever two individuals do the most kills, they get straight to the finals.
And then the finals is composed of all the teams that did really well in the invitationals.
And then, boom...
A thousand... easy $500 that I make it to the finals.
Yeah, there is a lot of... really...
Two teams got 10 challenges completed and they tied for first.
Oh my gosh.
By the way, it's actually...
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Who placed...
It's actually crazy though.
I'd be surprised if I get into the other two tournaments...
because apparently a lot of people signed up for these.
Like, a lot of people.
Obviously, I can't give out the numbers, but like...
They...
When I... they're like...
I had... they're like...
They're like, I have to check blank amount of applicants.
I was like, holy fuck!
And I just sent... I sent like...
a Doki Amber Doge emoji of him sleeping.
And I was like, good luck.
A lot... it was a lot of people.
I was just like...
I'm... man... that...
That's a lot of people you have to check, bro.
Holy fuck.
Um...
Can we see that emoji?
Okay, let me snip that emoji.
This is like the emoji I sent back.
I can like show it on stream now.
I...
Like, they're like being like, man, I have to check a lot of people.
And I... and they gave me the number and I was like, bro.
And then I sent back...
Oh, wait.
Whoops.
That's not it.
That is not it.
I need to like lock in this...
Fugi, so I don't accidentally...
I don't accidentally move the Fugi.
Okay, I need to like reset the...
Okay, I sent this picture back to them.
This is one of my favorite emojis.
I have like...
Okay, I use a lot of emojis.
That's just pictures of my dog.
Because...
Because my dog is like... is so good at giving you emotions.
Wait, let me... I'll show you the other ones.
Wait, I need to like send myself these emojis.
Okay, I have...
I have this one that is like...
That is me yelling at people when I'm like...
I have this one too.
And then I also have...
I also have this one.
Wait, I'll just...
Shoot.
I also...
I also have...
I also have this one.
I'm sorry.
My dog is just so good at giving me emotions.
It's showing emotion.
What can I say?
It's just so good.
So like... I... I like...
The majority of time, whenever people talk to me and I use like emojis...
It's just... all of it is just close up of my dog's face.
Because it's just so good.
It's like...
It's just point... Exactly!
It's like a point to be a meme.
Who's in my team?
It's Senox and...
And... Heenie.
Oh shit.
Wait, we can give clips?
Guys!
Fuck!
This sucks because I have no replay...
I'm not on Twitch!
We can't fucking show clips!
Someone!
Any YouTube editor right now.
Any YouTube clipper.
If you have any.
For those who have been recording this stream.
If you have funny videos of this stream.
Upload it now and I can put it in the...
Because...
You can also win money for having...
Um...
For having 1000...
You can win 1000 dollars each person.
For the two best clips.
Clippers!
I know we don't have clips.
But...
If you have a good clip from my stream.
Please upload it on YouTube.
And like...
I don't know.
Actually I don't.
Please!
Figure out some way...
To send this clip to me.
Oh!
Use the hashtag!
I have a clip hashtag!
Use my clips hashtag!
Guys!
We can win 1000 dollars...
So easily.
Use my hashtag!
DokiClips!
For all...
Any of the Apex clips we've made today!
And then...
And then we can...
We can win...
Win the vote.
We can win the vote by sheer...
Okay.
We're not gonna cheat guys.
We're not gonna...
It has to be actually funny guys.
So like...
We're gonna keep...
Going to do... Keep the same card for World's Edge.
And then a new card for Stormpoint.
So the challenges are the same.
Oh!
Oh the challenges are the same.
Does he mean like the ones we've completed are like...
We don't have to complete?
Like we're keeping the same ones?
Or are we genuinely just on the same card?
I think that's what everyone is asking.
I think like... Yeah I think everyone is asking that right now.
I think...
I think he meant like...
I guess like the challenges are the same but they reset?
Maybe?
Someone is asking if they carry over.
That's...
I mean it would make sense to carry over.
Because...
Like why...
Have to play 90 FOV every fucking game?
Please no.
Please.
I feel like it shouldn't though.
Like to be...
To make it fair for everybody.
Because like each...
Like you win 1500 for having the most challenges.
And like the person...
The team with the most challenges are ready.
In the first game.
Yeah they are already ahead.
They should reset.
Yeah you are right.
It should because it would be so easy for them to finish the other challenges.
I don't even think he has answered anybody yet.
I don't think anyone has.
I think he is thinking.
He is like wait this is a bad idea.
Because he was making the card.
I was talking to him.
He was trying to make the card.
I was just not prepared.
I think like halfway...
He didn't think the game was going to end that fast.
While he was making the card.
Also...
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Also we don't have emotes yet.
Because I was thinking...
I felt like...
I wanted to wait until my new skin suit was finished.
Before we have...
Before we upload new emotes.
I meant to upload...
People to my dock.
Because I don't want to...
I don't wanna like, I don't wanna like waste money and like have it remain.
Okay, but yes.
Oh, we just, do we just play Valkyrie Caustic then?
If it's staying the same?
No matter what?
Yeah, we might as well so we can get that.
Yeah, we might as well.
Guys.
I can play anyone but Valk to be honest.
Yeah, I cannot do Valk so I guess Senox is just automatically on Valk.
I'll take Gibby.
I can do Caustic.
Beautiful.
Okay, anyway.
Okay, if you guys have the clips.
Give me the links to it.
Give me the links to the clips.
If it's the same card we need to beat that one anyways.
On Dokie Clips.
Wait, what's my hashtag again?
Dokie Clips and then I'll post those clips into the Clip Channel.
Guys.
Guys, come on.
If I win a thousand dollars, we all win.
Guys.
We all win this together.
They are blowing this man up.
This is so true!
It's a team effort!
You win spiritually.
Guys, it's like we both felt the win together.
Um.
Oh yes!
Yes!
Also, might as well give the update because they're still trying to figure out the whole fucking team scenario at the moment.
But basically...
Basically, tomorrow it's not gonna be Resident Evil 4.
We're swapping Resident Evil 4 with the Who-phobia stream.
Do the scheduling.
Because I got Sayu and Amelie got Fruit.
So the schedule works better on Friday instead of Saturday.
So on Friday, we're playing with Amelie, Sayu, and Fruit.
And then Saturday, it's gonna be Resident Evil 4.
We swapped it because it was the best scheduling-wise for...
No, Sayu.
C.
Y.
Wait.
C.
Y.
U.
The voice actor.
Okay.
Here, here.
I'll type it down.
The voice actor.
I know.
It got confusing.
I'm gonna say it's Sayu.
Okay.
So...
So I got Sayu on my end and Amelie got Fruit.
So to match everybody's schedule because there was like four of us, you know?
And like Saturday, people would have... like Saturday, the schedule was conflicting for a lot of us.
So we decided to swap.
We decided to swap it for tomorrow instead of... instead of Saturday.
So I just wanted to give you guys the update for that.
Everybody's just debating.
Guys.
Okay.
So people...
There is a huge technical issue at the moment because people are debating right now about like whether or not to reset the cards.
And everything.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Alright.
So...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
I'm looking at the update.
I'm looking at the update right now.
We have to make a change to a few challenges.
We're completed as an...
Wait, what?
I don't even... I wasn't supposed to read that out loud.
Sorry.
Did I answer it?
Whoops.
Sorry.
They're talking about it right now.
They're still deciding.
They're still... I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to... I didn't leak anything.
I didn't leak anything, guys.
I didn't leak anything.
They're having a discussion about whether or not the challenges stack or they are... or they would keep going.
So one of the biggest issue right now is that there was 25 challenges.
But they didn't... they thought that we were gonna get 25 challenges or like close to 25 challenges.
And... but we sort of...
The closest was 10 challenges.
So they're trying to decide right now if like we're gonna keep the same card and seeing... and like just whoever gets the most type deal.
Because like no...
The closest the team got was 10 challenges and not 25.
Because like 25 was a lot.
Okay.
Let me... let me see if anybody got me the... some Doki clips that I can like spam.
We can win by sheer numbers of clips.
Chat.
We have so many...
Wait.
No.
We should not.
Because I would divide the vote.
Guys.
Don't divide the vote, guys.
Give me your best clips.
I realized if we spend too many clips, then it'll divide the votes too fast.
So we have to send... give me your best clips to like...
We cannot divide the votes.
Guys.
If... if we... we have to win this together.
What clips?
Clips from this stream.
I know there's no... there's no rewind.
But I believe in you.
I... I believe in you guys.
Clip master.
I need your strongest clips right now.
Because... but...
Guys.
But think of it this way.
If we... we can technically win...
Because they're thinking.
They're like...
Oh.
We might send it to like 500 per clip.
If we win all four of them, we...
Hahaha.
If we have all the four of the best clips, guys.
We... we can...
Guys.
Just think of it this way.
Four of the best clips.
Hahaha.
We can win all of them.
You can't handle... Guys.
I believe in you.
I believe in all of you.
Hahaha.
Someone's like, I feel so stupid right now trying to understand all of this.
I'm just vibing.
It's been one hour.
We played one game.
Hahaha.
No.
They're thinking of like dividing it by four.
So like instead of a thousand each person.
Um.
It's 500 per person.
So like if we just have too many good clips.
We can technically get all of them.
Hahaha.
We can...
How many games?
It's... six.
Hahaha.
It's... it's... it's six guys.
It's six.
Don't worry.
We can be here for six hours.
We can do this.
I... I believe in us.
I believe in us.
Okay.
Do not reuse the ones...
What?
Do not redo... Oh!
Oh!
Okay.
It stacks.
It's gonna stack.
It looks like it stacks.
Cause it says do not reuse...
Do the ones you've already completed.
Focus on completing the whole card.
Okay.
Did it say that?
Yeah.
Someone just said it in chat.
I think they were watching on stream.
So... so it doesn't...
That's... that's a bit unfair.
Not gonna lie.
Hahaha.
Obviously.
Alright.
Same card for our world's edge.
Oh!
We wipe.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Why... why is it different from the person above?
Okay.
So it's just fresh card.
It's the same card but it wipes every game.
Oh!
So we just redo as many as we can.
We wipe.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
We have to do...
We have to do the person...
We do it again!
I like how someone there was like, so we start all over after they were like, do not redo the ones you already completed.
Hahaha.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
So we want to do as many as we can for free, right?
Yeah.
90 FOV, 3 evil harvesters, uh, nades in a bag, 3 evacs or survival items, Yeah.
Valkyrie caustic, um...
I think we should...
Um... knock yourself, draw a heart, no attachments, alt 3 times.
That's about it.
The other ones are altico people.
Yeah.
I feel like we could just do all that in our POI.
We could do caustic alt.
Yeah.
We could do...
Oh yeah.
We could literally just lurk and do nothing and do nothing.
But wait.
Okay.
We'll say, Valk, you probably have to do the nade one because we some big boys.
Yeah.
I just do it at the start of the game.
The nade one.
Okay.
We could do that right off the bat.
And then like, we can have alt...
We'll try and find as many altixels as possible and give it all to one person.
Yeah.
That sounds good.
It's easy.
We could legit just all run a different sniper and whoever gets a knock finishes the challenge.
Wait.
Who's doing the no survival items?
Let's do it.
Let's survive the game.
Okay.
I feel like...
I guess it depends if we get...
If we have three evacs, we can do the three evacs.
If we don't, we can just do the don't use any.
I guess it's just how many we get.
Wait.
Is the evac a survival item?
I thought that meant like heals.
Yeah.
No.
It's just...
Heat shields, mobi and...
Yeah.
That's a survival slot.
That's not health, is it?
No.
Wait.
Is it survival?
I mean, wouldn't that just be a white heal?
Like, why would they call it a survival item?
Because it helps you heal up.
I guess.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, what's a survival item?
Is survival item the heals or survival...
It's just the survival items.
That's what they're called.
Like, the evacs and mobis.
The keybind is like mobis.
Oh.
Yeah.
It's called survival item on the keybind.
Okay.
So, we just don't use...
We just don't care about that one.
Yeah.
But, unfortunately, we have to choose if we want to get that point or get the point of using three evac towers at the same time.
I feel like...
Whichever one comes first, right?
Whichever one, yeah.
If we die before then, then we technically, we, you know...
Just don't use any until we get three.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
My dog is still on my stream.
So, we're still on the tree, right?
No.
We're countdown.
Oh, we're countdown now?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
I'm on Kasta.
We could go for the...
Gibby.
Where's Gibby?
Oh, I'm on her.
Okay.
I guess we're not doing that then.
I'm staying low by then.
Okay.
That is actually awful.
I didn't even know the game was starting.
I was looking at the fucking...
The thing.
It's awesome.
No, no.
You're good.
Can we get a restart?
Let's get a restart, you're nuts.
Wait, wait.
See you crashed.
Tell Temple your game crashed.
I actually just got a degree.
Okay.
Wait.
And we got no beacon?
We're getting grieved.
Tell your game you crashed.
I hate it here.
Tell Temple.
Turn.
I'm already trying to do it in scrims.
Turn off your stream right now!
Oh my god, when I just switched it to 90, my V is zoomed in so far.
I mean we don't have a beacon, we just loot the POI and stack up all the alt-excells.
We can alt three times still.
Yeah, I mean we just need to do the Loba.
Because Loba alt is so fast.
I can hit the button in the middle for you guys.
I'm just gonna run over here and start looting.
You can loot all this.
I'll loot this stuff.
Remember no attachments, He-me.
How could I forget?
In theory, you could technically do that one.
I could just do the no attachments and then pick up the care package guns.
Let me do the no attachments.
I'll just run sniper and pick up care package guns.
But that means no scopes though, because it's not an attachment.
It's alright.
Yeah, no scopes either, but...
Okay.
I'm trying to find more shield cells.
Well, it is pulling hard south.
Unfortunately.
Wait, can you give me your shield cells, He-me?
I can literally do the heart right now.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, this is actually harder than I expected.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to drop my shield.
Oh, do I?
That was the wrong nid.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Oh, what'd it have to be?
A frag grenade.
Here, here, here.
Jesus Christ.
Wait, I can do this.
No, I think I'll die if I do that.
No, you're good.
You're good.
It'll knock you no matter what.
You won't fall down.
You're right.
Oh, wrong one.
We gotta go.
Frag grenade.
We gotta go quick before this guy pulls up and kills us.
Oh, my God.
This heart is harder than I expected.
Did you finish the heart?
Wait.
Technically, yes.
I need more shield cells.
I need more.
Here, I'll give you here.
Here, here.
Take this.
My ult.
It's almost a heart.
Do it quick and then we gotta dip because we're about to just die.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Girl, what is this?
It's technically a heart.
If you look at it correctly.
Oh, I'm not.
Okay.
That's a heart.
Take the screenshot.
We do it on the ball.
We gotta go.
That's a heart.
Let's grab the support bin and then go for the beacon fissure and...
Did you take a screenshot?
I'm not gonna do that.
We can just take it from the VOD.
We can take it from the VOD.
Yeah, yeah.
We are shambles.
We're no beacon too.
White armor.
Okay.
All right.
Hit the support bin.
There's no armors on the ground.
Let's just go for it.
We're just gonna go for Eva harvesters and stuff.
Okay.
We got the heart.
We have to avoid people though because we have...
Okay.
How many nades do you guys?
I have almost bottom row all our...
I have zero nades.
Okay.
Give me your backpack.
I can do it because I don't have attachments anyway so I don't need anything.
I can just...
And then you can drop me all your nades.
Okay.
I can just...
I only need a couple...
I only need four more grenades and then I can fix it.
I don't have any.
Let's go for the Eva harvester.
I have so many shield cells though.
That's fine.
Can I have some?
I only have two.
Yeah.
All right.
We have to avoid everybody.
We can't fight right now.
Wait.
What are the other things that we need to do that's easy?
Three Eva harvesters, grenades in the backpack.
I have not found a single nade.
Here's one more nade.
Hold on.
I'm gonna grab this.
I can take it.
and then I'll just transfer it over.
I'm heading over to Senna.
Can we go Fissure to hit Beacon?
Yeah.
But isn't there somebody at Fissure?
They hit the UAV like...
Oh, no.
They're still here.
Back up.
Yeah.
Go up there.
Pylon interceptions.
Can we do first starter pylon interceptions?
We can play for this.
Play for what?
What did you say?
The Eva harvester over here.
We need two more.
Okay.
I only need two more grenades and then I can actually pick up one.
I have one here.
Here.
Yeah.
I'm looking for a grenade.
I'm looking everywhere.
And we can play for care packages too.
I just got to remember not to pick up attachments.
I know.
I saw someone over there just now.
Yeah.
Let's go this way then.
I have zero white.
We might just be sitting in...
We might just sit in zone half the game.
I'm not going to lie.
There's a vault here.
We can get this vault.
They're fighting up here.
We might be able to do a third party this.
Yeah.
Oh.
That's smart.
This right here.
I'm just going to try to knock one with Sentinel and get the...
You get the challenge.
Yeah.
I was going to say, is that smart to...
They're moving back.
They're moving to you.
They're coming to you.
Yeah.
I'm running.
Go.
This is awful.
I need two more grenades and I can pick up loot.
I can throw my ult.
I can throw my ult, but like...
I'm not here.
Let's do it.
I know.
Let's do it up here.
I'm staging side.
Okay.
Let's see if I can...
Look into staging.
We're actually just passive this challenge.
Let's see.
No nades.
Maybe here?
Vince?
No nades.
I got one.
Oh.
Thermite.
Oh my God.
I got it.
I don't have any loot.
Back up.
I'm gonna port.
Play on the trailer and stay healthy.
Okay.
Tell me if I need to drop it.
I'm looking.
I don't see them yet.
We're gonna have to just run into a zone because I don't have loot to fight.
Bloodhound ult.
Okay.
I'm dropping it now.
They're to my left.
There's a guy above us in countdown.
Come back.
Whoa!
Wow.
This is scary.
We need to go far.
This is so scary.
We are just little rats.
How many White Heels do you have?
I have two Phoenix Kits.
I have two Med Kits as well.
We just have to loot the zone.
We can use your ult here.
You have enough to sustain for a little bit.
I'm going to go grab the Evil Harvester.
You might as well use your ult to get one of the other challenges.
You can spam yours if you want.
You can pop it up there.
Or wherever.
It doesn't matter.
I'm stuck.
No!
Let's go to Monument.
Okay.
I'm going to need some White Heels from somebody.
You can give it to him.
I have four Syringes and one Phoenix Kit.
Okay.
I have three Syringes.
Give me a couple.
I have zero.
We just need to get into Monument.
We're little rats.
I'm just going to run for now.
At least I can pick up loot now.
True.
Rats.
We are the rats.
This is like the most...
The poorest I've ever been in Apex Legends.
Yeah.
This is awful.
Are you entertaining chat?
It's the ghetto.
Okay.
Senox, here's some of these Syringes.
Thank you.
Oh, I have a Med Kit.
Oh, just one.
What is this?
That's fine.
I can give you one Phoenix Kit.
We get it off of this Evo.
We get the...
Oh, keep it in front of us.
Okay.
Do they see us?
Oh, I hope not.
Well, I'm just chilling in this corner.
They see us.
I'm not peeking.
I'm just going to let...
I'm chilling in this corner.
They're running right now.
They're going left-stroke.
When... Alright.
We need to have another ult and also grab that Harvester.
And then we should be good.
Yeah.
I'm going for the Harvester right now.
We got to work the zone because we don't have enough Whitelands to stay here.
They're shooting someone else.
Wait.
I heard someone shooting.
I'm going to go for the Evo Harvester.
Right here.
I'm going to grab this and then come back.
Should we just go train side?
Yeah.
I had to drop the Vulcan.
I didn't even get to pick it up.
I had to grab the Neds.
I don't even know if we have enough...
Let's check Harvester.
I think we have enough.
I think we have to go through Harvester.
We have 30 seconds.
There is a team to our left though.
They... Was it the one that Valk ulted?
Yeah.
There was a Valk ult but I think they were shooting at someone.
Okay.
Just be careful.
Alright.
I still don't even have ammo.
This is awful.
Wait.
What ammo do you need?
Oh my gosh.
You have the most niche ammo too.
Shotgun and Sniper.
I would love to help you.
Shotgun?
Oh yeah.
No.
I can't use a gun with attachments.
My ult is at 1080.
Yeah.
Let's go Harvester and LeBolt.
And then I'll have Port.
We have to try to Port in the zone and survive.
I guess we don't use any survival items.
We don't have any either.
Do you have your another ult yet?
Not yet.
I just had an 80.
Oh 80?
Okay.
The moment you do it, just chuck it there and then mark it off.
Let's go throw on med kits on the crafter.
Just place it out because there might be someone here.
But...
I'm going to close the door so we know.
Can we hit the... Could you hit the beacon maybe?
So we get purple?
Yeah.
Alright guys.
Yay we have our ult too.
They might know we're here now though.
But we can mark that off.
This is my third ult right?
Yeah that's your third one.
Yeah that's third.
Alright.
Fighting behind us.
Harvester show.
Alright let's work towards... we gotta get in the zone.
We're gonna dive.
We're shambles dude.
I'm gonna grab a med kit then just in case.
Yeah I'm throwing on a med kit.
Actually I need to throw on a bat.
I don't have any shield heals either.
I can chop you bats.
There's another LeBolt right?
Yeah.
I'm throwing on some meds then we should get going.
This team might try to gatekeep us so I'm gonna go ahead.
Does my P20 need no attachments or it doesn't matter?
Oh no he can have attachments cause Synax is running no attachments.
Okay okay.
I didn't know if the P20 had to be naked.
Careful there was people on the right.
They might be walking up.
Flying over us.
Two teams flying in.
On bridge.
They're on bridge.
Woah.
Wait there's an evil harvester.
That's Blaston.
The last evil harvester.
We already got three.
I thought we did it.
We got three?
I thought we got two.
I thought we did three.
Oh.
Yeah we have three.
We have three.
Okay.
I didn't hear any of them.
You see how many people are above us?
No.
We need to just get in.
They know they landed on bridge though is all.
Yeah I'm walking up.
Someone look at the bridge when we get up here.
I'm gonna try to scout some other way.
They're on the platform.
Yeah.
Oh they ulted too.
You see anybody in this building?
Yeah there's a team there.
There's another team that read the polls.
Damn that weed arc sucks.
We need to deploy to the bridge too.
There's another team on bridge.
Just right.
They might fight and we're gonna have to throw it out.
There's like people everywhere and we don't have any evokes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw them run from uh, we deployed to the bridge.
Do you have uh, do you have cells?
Uh yeah.
Do you need?
I wanna charge this cause it's my only gun.
Woo.
They're trying to get those charge sentries off.
We might have to just hug Logon and run in with them.
We have like no time.
I still have port so.
No team is dying though.
That's the scary part.
They're still right in front of us.
These guys aren't moving.
Just go left, just go left.
They're waiting too.
They're all waiting and they're just gonna valko.
We don't have valk though.
This is awful.
It's been scuffed since the beginning.
Come in the RV and rat.
Nothing good has happened since the start.
Here's some shield cells.
Yeah we got the all.
Let's go.
We're just gonna have to run in last second and I'm gonna pray I can hit the goat or something.
We just don't have valk here.
Is there nobody?
Can we move forward here?
All in on Senox right here.
There might be a team in this building so we just gotta go together.
Alright.
All in.
I'm running forward and going for a point.
I don't even know where I'm gonna be able to get it to be honest.
It's okay.
I fully trust you.
I stopped trusting.
I'm dropping here for now.
You can take it.
We're starting to save here.
Can you get a gen down?
I think we're good here.
We have to shoot this.
We have to shoot on my ping.
I'm genning.
You're right here.
Shoot this.
This team's on our right as well.
Careful.
I got him.
He's resing though.
He's resing.
We have to kill this.
We have to kill this team.
We have to kill that team.
I'm looking.
I'm looking for you.
Trying to cancel that.
Here.
We're running up.
Oh, no.
Goodbye.
In the corner right here.
80?
Yeah.
I'm looking.
I'm seven.
I'm throwing all my arcs in that corner.
Whoa.
You hit my little shield.
I'm farming.
We can kill this guys.
Flash.
He's flashed.
Cracked one.
Cracked another one.
Oh my god.
I just took it.
Wait, wait.
I'm actually trying...
It's where?
It's horrible bro.
It's horrible.
No, and it's out!
No fucking way.
I'm Q, I'm Q.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
Do we, uh, do you have low bolt?
Do you have low bolt?
I'm gonna pop ulti so it's support.
No, no, no.
We have to just, just play to kill them.
We have to kill them.
Look at them, look at them, look at them.
Shoot the fuck off.
Oh, I couldn't get it.
I got like...
Crack him.
I almost cracked it.
Alright, do you have low bolt maybe?
No, yeah.
No.
There's a team above us, a team above us.
Yep.
Wait, I don't need this maybe.
I have port, I have port.
Okay, I'm pro- oh this sucks.
There's actually so many people.
I don't see a team directly above- Are they just in here, riding?
Like, where are they?
I heard footsteps.
I'm gonna go scout it, I'm gonna go scout it.
Let's just all go together.
They're right here, they're right here.
They're just jumping out.
They're jumping down on the left.
We can just mirror this.
Yeah, yeah.
They scanned it.
I might have to port up through here and just get a port and a lower launch, maybe.
So I think they're holding the round.
Yeah, they're hard holding.
We gotta go around, we gotta go around.
We have to go now.
Yep, I'm gonna bat and then port from the corner.
There's a team in this building, okay?
Up here?
There definitely is.
Alright, good luck!
Actually, just run it, just run it.
I think they're all gonna bot-cult.
Jesus Christ.
Come off, come off, come off, come off.
There's a lot of barrels.
I'm gonna drop a corn up here for you.
Oh, I used a raw fucking gun for this.
Alright.
Ow.
Do you have gen?
No, 72.
Okay.
You have to come and instantly look right, instantly look right.
There's a team on our right, team on our right.
Try to gen if you have it soon.
I don't, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we try to, we watch the walk-in and then we try to look left at third party and get some kills.
A full team's gonna walk up right here.
We have to be the one to climb.
Okay.
I'm looking.
There's a full team behind us right here as well.
Behind this rock.
Behind this rock, they're shooting the rock now.
Cracked on?
Right here?
They killed the team.
This rock, this rock, they're in front.
I'm looking, I'm looking at this, I'm looking at this rock.
There's a team riding in this corner right here.
We might have to go kill them.
Or directly above us.
I have scans above 95%.
Can you level up?
Yep.
Okay.
Sold this.
Oh my god, care package guns.
I'm just grabbing both.
Okay, we need to look to kill them.
I think there's still a team riding above us.
They're sitting in this corner right above us.
We have nades.
Do you have any nades?
No, no nades.
You can look in the...
There's nades here.
I have gold knock.
Here, here.
Here's a nade.
I'm not...
There's nobody here.
I'm gonna drop this.
Drop the knock.
They're riding in this corner.
Can we try to kill them maybe?
Can someone grab this knock?
I can grab it.
I got it.
I threw a nade here for you.
Any ulti cells?
Can I get gold helmet?
Yeah, here.
I'm gonna grab the nade.
Any ulti cells?
I'm not gonna have port.
Yeah, I've got one here.
Nope, I don't have any.
Yeah, I'm just gonna go for another port and we're gonna have to pray it's fucking decent.
Maybe you can try to see if you can kidnap somebody.
Can we wrap the logon and try to kill this team?
They're sitting like right in this corner.
Oh, there's a team right above.
I'm gonna port.
I mean, if you want to just go for the kidnap.
Oh, true.
True?
Just like it.
We both said true as fuck.
I mean, that's like...
Okay, take port.
Take port.
Okay.
They're good.
Hug the wall.
We're safe here.
They're evac'ing right above us.
Just look up.
Just get fences and look up.
They're sitting right above us.
We gotta get a logon here.
Yeah, we can look.
We can look.
Just wait for zone to close.
I'm marking it.
They have to take it up and we have to knock.
They're gonna peek above us.
The only place they kill us is above.
I'm gonna make sure nobody takes our port.
Oh my god.
They're just sitting above us still.
They have caustic.
Take port.
Oh, there they are.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm on this.
I'm up.
I'm fighting.
Oh no.
I'm healing.
No, I'm dead.
I can't wait the moment I turn around from the portal to...
In case the Nox live.
Is that considered a kitnaft?
If you think it is.
He's finishing me.
Oh, no.
He's giving me the finishing.
Wait, should I go pop a finisher on this guy?
Yes.
Yes, you should.
Wait, his teammates are on him.
It's all 10.
No.
It's okay.
Just try and get anything.
He's finishing me.
They're resing it.
I have no meds and no ammo.
It's okay!
Just get a knock if you can!
Now that we're dead, we can start marking off stuff on the card.
Oh... that is a good spot.
Oh no!
Look!
If they can't see you, you can't see them too.
Oh wait, yeah, we got the one with the care package gun kill because I killed that Lifeline.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Care package gun kill.
Unfortunately, not looking too good.
We didn't use a survival item.
Oh, true!
We got the heart.
I got the knock.
I'm gonna go for the kidnap for the point.
Okay, I'm gonna shut up and count.
Where are they?
I got them!
Yes!
Kidnap!
We did it!
Wait, did you actually?
Yeah.
It's okay, we got the kidnap!
Okay, so hang on.
I count.
One...
So from the top, we got FOV, three eva harvesters, nades, You only had two care pack weapons, right?
Yeah, we only had the two.
Did you guys have any?
No, I didn't.
You didn't get any knocks with the sniper, did you?
No, I got one shot.
Got the frag knock, got the shield cells, got the no attachments, and got the ult three times.
And you got the knock with the care package.
That's nine.
We did the heart?
Did we get the heart?
Yeah.
Okay, heart.
Oh, nice!
Good job.
Damn, if we had one more care pack, that actually wouldn't have been a ton.
I know!
I mean, ten was the winning last time.
Yeah.
But I think now people know.
But this time, people didn't play comp, so...
Yeah, people already know what to do, though.
Yeah.
Alright.
Did we not get...
We didn't get any knocks with the P20, right?
No.
No, I shot at the lifeline, but I think you got that one, which is still a win.
We got nine.
We're team six, and we got nine.
Yeah!
Typing that was very satisfying.
We improved!
And the team above was fourth on team 20!
Not a joke, that's hilarious.
I've never played a more shambles Apex Legends game.
That was so rough.
I felt like you know it was going to be rough when, you know, we already picked the wrong characters.
I know.
It was raps after that.
Honestly, that one, the fuckup got us two points, though.
We got the care package and the kidnap.
That's true, that's true.
But that was like, honestly, I was awful.
the most scuffed game I've ever played.
I was awful.
Somebody got 11?
It was third!
Even though that doesn't mean we win anything.
Oh wait, no, no, no, they didn't get 11, they got, it was team 11 that got seven.
Seven came in.
Well, the team got ten anyways, unfortunately.
Yeah.
But we're in the top percentile.
We got nine!
Good stuff, guys.
Honestly, they were not too bad to do in the POI before we leave.
Were we kind of in shambles without the rotate?
Yes, but...
Yeah, I think it was smart to just do all the challenges on the POI and then start leaving.
Because everybody is Valk.
Everybody was Valk, so it didn't hurt us rotating because everyone was just Valk rotating out.
There's actually so many teams on edge.
Almost every single team just sits in their POI doing the challenges.
Yeah, everybody did.
Almost every team had nine.
I guess we gotta, for the last game, we need to try to do the ones quick, and then I think we should look for a third party so we can get the knocks with the guns and then like a...
Because we can stick a down person too and then finish them.
That would have been a lot.
One of us gave that one team a finisher.
Yeah, Gibby's ass sat on me, bro.
Just mean...
Okay, I can do the heart again.
It's so...
I didn't realize how... I forgot like...
The shield cells...
They can go anywhere.
That's the worst part.
My little scuffed heart.
Guys...
Why was the heart a challenge?
I thought like... I was like, oh yeah, that's easy.
I can like just put down my shield.
And I was like, wait.
Wait a minute.
You cannot just put down your shields.
You see the... I mean like...
If we're talking about abstract here...
Like abstract wise...
It sort of looked like a heart.
Oh my god.
That was...
That was fucking rough.
I think I spent like...
Like 80% of the time in that...
In our POI.
Just trying to make that fucking one heart.
It's a mod in our...
A team got 13.
Holy shit.
What the fuck did you do?
We have one team that had 13.
Welp.
It's okay.
Top 5.
I think.
I mean from 3...
From 3...
To like...
To 9 points?
That's pretty good.
Top 5?
No.
No, no, no.
Top 5.
Spam cells and then remove to get the heart.
Okay, but then you find enough cells for that.
The hardest part was that I did not have enough cells for that.
That was the...
That was the hardest part.
Improvement!
Exactly!
Every game we improve.
Chat.
That's all that matters.
If every game we improve...
If every game we improve... Do we have POIs yet?
Then that's all that matters.
Epi Center?
Oh my...
Okay, we have Survey too?
Thanks.
Oh, that's pretty good.
I thought it was just Epi.
Alright, Epi Survey.
What's the loot path?
One person Survey, one person Epi, one person Skyhook Tunnel.
Skyhook Tunnel?
Oh!
Well that's what it is in comp.
I don't know if people will...
Well, I mean everybody has like one pro player.
I guess everyone has their set drop spots too.
I can do the tunnel.
Just in case there's people up there, I can just run away or some shit.
And then one person Epi, and wherever the beacon is you can just land on.
Oh my gosh.
We're Gibby, Caustic, Valk, so...
I don't really have a preference on where.
Do you mind, Widoki, where you land?
I don't mind.
I don't really have a preference.
Caustic, just go Epi if there's beacon.
Yeah.
I'll just go to the beacon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
Should I do the no attachment one again?
Okay, Epi.
I'll go where the beacon...
I had to make it P20 for most of that game.
I feel like...
I feel like the P20 person should have the no attachments in the end.
That's what I feel like too.
I feel like it's just easier to like...
It's just... justify.
You do the attachments, I'll do the grenade one then.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
That sounds good.
Yeah, that sounds good.
And then I...
make the heart.
Alright.
I feel like I'm gonna waste most of my time trying to do that.
No, you're actually different on the no.
From the one game you like practice.
You're right.
I have the experience now.
It should be easy.
Guys, where are my clips?
Guys, where are my...
Where are my...
Guys!
You can't say clip that!
I still don't see any clips in the Doki Clips... in the Doki Clips hashtag!
Too busy watching...
Too busy watching... I'm still just gonna run a sniper every game and try to knock somebody.
Do something...
What do you mean?!
My entire existence is funny.
This is why I'm a streamer!
My entire life is a joke.
Ah, too real.
Too real.
Alright, we have...
I feel like... Hey, we're faster now!
One hour a game!
It is 30... 40 minutes a game.
We're like cutting down our time.
We're speedrunning this.
Chat, that's great.
Thank God.
We made it pretty far though.
I don't think I can play like six hours.
I don't think I can do six hours.
It'd be a lot easier if you get a good zone.
Because you can just do all the things sitting in zone and then you just get everything else done.
Because you're just in God's spot.
Like just bugging people and stuff.
Doki the Joker, take your time.
But yeah, we still have...
We still have four more games left.
Chat.
These like...
It's just scary because everybody's not dying.
That's like the scariest part.
Nobody is fucking dying.
So like everybody is just trying to...
Try to do their challenges and I'm just like...
Please, please spare me.
Please spare us.
Let us go.
This is NA Apex.
What do you mean nobody is dying?
We actually just weren't passing them.
What do you mean no one's dying?
This is NA Apex.
Please spare.
Three care package weapons and three red armor.
Yeah, we weren't lucky enough to get the three red armor.
Oh my god, somebody had one.
Thank god that wasn't me.
Guys, I told you we're improving.
We didn't have one.
Look at us.
We're getting better and better.
I think like there's some teams that don't even put their points.
Because they're like, what's the point?
They didn't...
Oh my god.
Not last.
We're in the top five.
Top five.
That's what I like.
These relaxing moments between rounds.
Yeah.
This is nice.
It's nice.
It's nice, but then like...
Sometimes I wish it wasn't too long.
You know?
I just...
Let me play the game!
I just wanna play.
Please.
Let me play.
Oh my gosh.
Like yesterday, I was so stressed the fuck out yesterday.
That I mostly just...
I was mostly just like sleeping.
I was so fucking...
I was just so fucked up, man.
I was like...
I didn't get any work done.
And then like one of the things I had to do.
That was due yesterday.
I got like a message about it.
They're like, um...
Doki, we're sort of behind schedule.
And I was like, fuck!
I was like, I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I was so...
No, I'm kidding.
I was like, I was so busy yesterday.
I...
I was so tired.
I just wanted to sleep.
I didn't say that.
I just said, I was so busy yesterday.
With behind the scenes work.
I'm so sorry.
And then I like, I couldn't get it done today.
I'm behind schedule.
But they understand.
And I sent the stuff that I had to do.
Right before...
Before I had to...
Start my stream.
I'm so sorry I'll never sleep again.
Let's see.
Uhhhh...
Wait, each...
And advances to the final...
Oh!
Wait, what?
Wait!
Wait, they changed the rules!
If you win for most challenges per game, you advance to the finals.
I thought it was overall.
Yeah, we just have to get the most in one game.
The top team that wins the challenges for that game gets to advance.
Yeah!
Yeah, I thought it was like...
I thought it was overall, but it seems like...
Well, it's actually too good for us for the three.
At least that doesn't count.
We just have to...
So if you win just one of them, you can go to the finals.
Yeah.
So we gotta...
We gotta start getting some of these actual fighting ones.
The challenges.
Yeah, we need to fight somebody.
Yeah, Xenox, you need to...
Actually, it was physically impossible to fight people.
I had four set up bullets.
I had four set up bullets and no attack wounds.
And no meds.
And I had to fight us two to get the fighting one.
It was hard.
I know, I felt so bad.
Like, you were fiending for that lobalt.
And I was like, no, it's not ready.
We're the babies here.
You're supposed to carry us.
I need to not do the no-attachment ones.
Yeah, exactly.
I was hoping to just get a care package gun.
Do you want to do the no-attachments one, Doki?
Wait, me?
Yeah, I feel like you haven't been nerfed enough yet.
But you're on the P20, though.
So...
Yeah, but my other gun...
doesn't get attachments either.
I don't know.
That plus 90 is rough.
Oh, but you can just run the vault.
You don't need attachments on the vault.
It's so easy.
I don't know, I think you need to be nerfed a little bit.
to like join the group.
I mean, I am nerfed.
I'm making the heart.
The heart is a very hard thing to do.
Like, I can't loot when I'm making the heart.
That's practically a nerf.
Right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, all in all, this is like Senox's decision.
Why is it all up to me?
Why am I the leader?
Because you're the IGL.
I just want to be the content creator.
I'm the content creator!
I too am a content creator.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What do you mean?
Okay, okay.
I'm pretty sure I'm the more content creator compared to you.
I'm pretty sure.
If we look at stats here regarding hours streamed on Apex.
I just started two weeks ago, so I have the least hours streamed for Apex.
I don't stream Apex.
I'm a content creator.
I just don't stream at all.
I create content, but like I don't put it out.
You literally have a liquipedia!
That invalidates everything you say!
I couldn't even get a liquipedia!
Anybody can get one of those.
No!
I tried to get one and they deleted my liquipedia because my tournaments are not official enough.
They deleted my liquipedia, so I know that's a lie.
They're like, your tournaments are too much on content creation!
And not pro enough!
Nobody can outsmart me!
Weird flex!
It's true!
People try to make me a liquipedia!
It's got a nice little zone.
They deleted it!
Yeah.
I just got here.
Did we win?
Maybe like mentally.
I think we won.
We won the mental battle!
That's all that matters!
It doesn't matter!
It doesn't...
The other things don't matter!
We won the mental battle!
Alright.
Remember to pick your legends this time!
Oh shit.
Caustic.
Oh my god.
Good call.
Nice.
We got one point already!
We did it!
Nice.
Our one point.
Go us!
Alright, we got this!
Beacon?
No beacon?
We don't need beacon.
That's fine.
One person epi, one person...
I'll do the tunnel ops in case.
Just be careful epi.
Actually no, you should be good.
I don't think the comments...
I'm gonna go to epi then.
Dude up!
Meet up in survey.
Alright.
So I don't gotta move?
Perfect?
Yeah, you get to stay there.
I mean, if you wanna swap, I don't mind.
I'm gonna turn this into a home over here.
You know, I'm free to swap with you.
Out of the goodness of my heart.
I'm gonna be homesteading.
You'll find me churning butter by the time you guys get here.
Okay, I hope I don't die.
Don't die.
That's all I hope for.
You'll be fine.
Just talk to him nicely.
Yo, I'm getting ratted.
This guy is a freak.
Alright, guess I'm coming to save the epi.
Wait, you already lost your home?
What happened?
The skyhook guy landed on me.
And I didn't get a gun.
Then fight him!
Why are you scared?
I don't have a blaster.
I don't have a gun.
Oh, you got the gun first.
Damn, no beacon.
Sucks.
I hope you guys grab all the shield cells.
Oh yeah, I have three nades on me right now.
I only have... I have three on me.
And also a blue backpack.
We can just stack nades and then drop them all to one person.
Yeah.
That's the plan.
I'm gonna go up.
See if there's anything.
Wait, they're pushing us.
They're inting us.
Wait, what?
Already?
I think so.
Trying to come link with you.
He's sitting in the building.
Wait, what is this guy doing?
Do I come over or leave?
Yeah, you should come over.
I'm heading over now.
Oh my god.
I have no shield cells.
I'm flying on the rock.
They're walking up.
I'm heading over right now.
I don't know if I'm getting shot or what.
I'm popping surges.
Where are they?
I only see Gibby right now.
He was on the building.
I see him.
They're running up.
I'm popping surges.
I saw one.
Yeah.
I can't see you.
No LOS there.
Wait, what is this guy doing?
He's actually just trolling and playing for fun.
Wait, what?
Are we good?
Yeah, we're good.
Anyone have a blue bag?
I have a blue bag.
Yeah.
I need to go craft a boat.
I have a Valkyr.
Can you guys give me your shield cells?
I'm gonna make a heart now.
I have zero.
I only have four.
Alright, I'm gonna try and do this.
Does this look like a heart?
Okay.
I will attempt this part.
Let's play for...
Let's go grab this Evo in the tunnel.
And then let's hit the balloon and go for the vault.
We have to play slow anyways.
We didn't get bacon unfortunately.
Alright.
Here's four.
This can be a heart.
It is!
It looks like a heart!
It does.
Yes!
Look!
Look at that!
Okay, I need, I need, I need Senox to come over your screen.
It looks like a heart!
If it looks like it, it's fine.
It doesn't have to be perfect.
It is!
Okay, there you go.
We did it.
That's a heart enough.
Let's go up here.
And hit the Evo.
And then we're gonna go for the vault.
I can vault call back there.
Do we have enough nades to do the nade bag thing?
I have three right now.
I have three.
Let's just all hold each other.
Like nades until we have enough.
So one person isn't scuffed.
Wait, you have nine on you?
We have enough.
Yeah.
Three, six, nine is a full bag?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll do it up here on the balloon.
I'll give you the nades and then go grab the Evo and come back.
Wait.
They're riding in here.
What are these guys doing?
Well then I guess we don't do that.
They're so cringe.
Here, just do it under here I guess.
I'm gonna drop you all the nades and then go.
Alright, I'm gonna drop all of this in.
Don't take my stuff please.
He's walking up, he's walking up.
I'm slowing down.
Okay, if he's walking up I can't do this anymore.
He took my nades!
Oh, they're above us.
Yeah, I threw my nades away.
Can you come back to me with bubble or no?
Okay.
So we left a bunch of nades on that ground.
I picked up one of them.
I picked up... I have four.
Is it a solo Gibby?
It's not.
Almost cracked Gibby.
Gibby's one, Gibby's one.
I have to heal.
Knock Gibby, knock Gibby.
Oh nice, you got the knock.
They're gonna rez.
Let's just back up, I don't have loot.
Let's just go to the vault.
Come to me and I'm gonna valk behind this building.
Wait, was that one of the challenges?
The knock?
Wait, there's a new team on the front.
Can we get in the building?
They're trying to port.
They're trying to get in the building.
He Q'd out.
We're gonna try to re-valk.
We gotta get out of here.
Come to me.
We're here.
Outside, outside.
Yay!
We're gonna fly front and go to the skyhook vault.
We have to play for evil harvesters.
Alright, pick me a longbow or a scythe.
I'm gonna go for the sentinel.
I guess I can pick up a different gun.
Alright.
Do we have one evil harvester, right?
We don't have any.
Yeah, we do.
I got one.
Let's hit this vault and get this one back here.
We can play for red armor if we get the vault.
Alright.
I'm dropping a gold lightmaker.
I'm gonna say we can find more names.
They're just gonna keep WKing as we stay here.
It might be a team that already got the challenges, so they're just playing for kills.
Like they could go...
Ready?
Is 20 squads up?
There's no way.
Oh, no.
Like if you win one of the games, you don't...
Oh, you can't win twice.
Yeah, they're just playing to kill people.
Because they advanced to the finals already.
Yeah.
They just get to relax.
Tell me that's not crest.
That guy's gonna get a talking to after this game if that's crest.
Oh, yeah?
Gold does here.
Huge.
Remember no attachments, Mimi.
Oh, wait.
Whoa!
No attachments.
Just throw it out.
If you haven't used it yet.
I haven't used it.
Be careful.
Can we get on this roof?
They might land on us.
We might have to fight them here.
I'm gonna fly roof.
We're good.
How many nades do you guys have?
I only have four.
I have two.
I have six, seven, eight.
Okay, we need two.
Just scrap loot.
And we're gonna play for the evos and stuff.
Wait, there's an evil hardy, sir.
I'm gonna grab that.
I need a Valk ult two more times.
I only popped it once so far.
I'm gonna grab this evil harvester.
Grab the evil harvester and then...
Are you...
Wait, so I'm the one that's doing no attachments.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, you're the one with no attachments.
Can you...
Can you hit beacon?
Yeah, I can.
I'm gonna run over now.
I just wanna see if I can find some nades.
I haven't seen any.
I have two right now.
I have four.
We have a minute.
We're gonna hit beacon and get going.
We need one more evil harvester.
We need six more nades.
I'm gonna peek in the countdown.
There's a guy above us.
We're gonna Valk ult.
We can come back here.
I have 5%.
Do we have enough nades to do the nade one quick?
No, no.
We need six.
Oh, you have five?
I have five now.
Okay, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
We need three.
We need three more.
I have two.
There's another one up here.
So we need two more.
I can grab one right now.
I'm gonna grab this one.
Let's try to do it in this building so we can Valk ult and actually pull the game.
We need two more nades and we should be good.
I just want another sniper.
No nades.
Nope.
Alright, whatever.
Let's Valk ult here.
I'm not even sure it's gonna be open.
There's still 19 teams.
Let's play for...
We might just play for the tracks.
I don't know if we can get into Mirage.
Go last slide for now.
We can hit this evil harvester and get our third one.
There's a guy on it.
There's a guy there.
There's a team.
Does he have teammates?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a team in the left side.
Go countdown.
Do we have any health exiles?
Nope, no.
My last syringe.
Use that up now.
Another nade right here.
Can you hold this?
That means we need one more.
Yeah, I can hold it.
I can hold it.
Let's look for one more and then get going.
Just need one more.
I'm gonna scout.
Do we see anybody Mirage?
I'm gonna look around and see if we can find one more nade.
We might look to play a top Mirage if we can.
Let's get going.
Uh oh, there's no nades in here.
We're on bridge.
I'm gonna scout Pound and Mirage.
Was that our third Valkal?
No, we need one more.
There's a caustic trap in this valley.
Watch out.
There's nades here?
There's nades?
Then we have it.
We have enough nades.
I'm dropping all my nades.
I just dropped all your nades there and I'll just do it.
I'm picking up white meds.
They flew in.
I didn't even see one to Mirage.
Oh, they dropped it.
On the balcony.
I have white meds.
Do all the nades on these bodies.
We're gonna run out.
I'm dropping my nades.
I got it!
Yay!
You can pick up all your loot.
Do you need white meds?
I'm dropping a med kit and four surges.
I have med kits.
We might slide down and grab this.
And then try to play.
We're gonna have to play slow.
Alright.
Is there anyone in graveyard in front of us?
I don't think so.
There's a harvester right there.
Yeah, let's play for this fence right here.
I'll grab the Evo.
We can just go straight to the fence.
There's a team top Mirage there so be careful.
Might beam you.
Oh yeah, they're looking.
Bubble it if you have to.
We finished our... do you have any surges?
I only have med kits.
I'm dropping a Phoenix if you don't pop that.
Careful, they might nade someone.
We're gonna have to bubble here.
They're right above us.
I'm just gonna med kit then.
We're gonna use our third valkal to get in.
Okay.
Do you want to bubble for it?
This is my last meds by the way.
I can give you a couple of shield heals.
Here you go.
I can give you some.
What kind of heals do you need?
I just need syringes.
I don't have any...
I drop three.
Wait, what?
Bubble, bubble, bubble, bubble.
Give me ult in time.
I ulted in time.
I'm playing back here.
We played a kill this time.
Can you maybe crawl to the back of this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I can't.
This ult is not your ult?
Just keep crawling.
We can play rez.
20 seconds.
Was it just the rat?
I don't know.
One died.
Popping a bat.
Can you play rez?
Just play rez.
We have to rez and valk ult out.
I'm gonna drop my golds.
She should get 50.
Here, I'm dropping gold rez.
I'm dropping gold rez.
Oh, they snatched that shit.
Wait, what?
Loba snatched it.
Oh my god.
That is so unfortunate.
I might be dead to the zone.
Oh, okay.
You survived.
I'll bub as soon as we drop.
If we need to.
We have to just fly far and we might drop down into lava.
I think I might just die.
Can you bubble instantly?
Come on, bitch.
I'm phoenixing.
We play this platform and we might have to drop down into lava.
Third harvester in front.
I don't have any.
Okay.
Slide forward and then we have to look at our backs.
Slide forward and look behind us.
Loba ult.
And we gotta look behind us.
Do any of you guys have...
Behind, behind, behind.
In the corner, 120.
I can get it.
I'm just gonna med kit.
How long on the next bubble?
10 seconds.
We're gonna swing wide and bubble and kill the loba on the cart.
I might need this.
3, 2...
Let's go, let's go.
1, 1, 1.
Oh, he fucked up.
What?
Nice.
Looted and we gotta go back.
He's the one that took the...
She's the one that took that shit.
I got it here.
Oh, you got it already?
I'm shooting at you.
Any ulti cells?
No.
I can just give this.
Do we have any bats?
Oh my gosh, what am I getting shot at?
I have a bat.
I dropped my bat.
I'm dropping some cells on the ground.
I'm just looking for roots.
Wait, I can regen my HP over.
There's a full team in here.
Wait, did you ever knock yourself with the frag?
No, we haven't.
Do you want to do it right now?
Oh my god.
Here's a frag.
Here's a regular frag.
I'm gonna do it.
Take the gold res and res me with it.
Yeah, you should do it.
Oh my god, I'm almost gone.
The building.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Wait, we actually might have just...
We might have just threw them.
We have to slide up to their fence, okay?
Slide to the fence.
They're right close.
We're playing slow.
We're gonna play slow.
No, he couldn't.
I have gold res.
You have gold res.
No, I'm dead.
I never... You gave me gold.
That's fine.
They're on you.
That was too thick.
I don't even think we live.
I'm not gonna lie.
We were too thick.
Oh my god.
Bad idea.
To drop.
It's okay.
I can watch.
For like a couple of seconds.
It's okay.
How many times did we Vel'Koz?
I think that was...
That was our third.
Yeah.
We should be fine.
I'm gonna play for a longbow knock and a finisher, I think.
That was too thick.
There's so many people.
Oh my gosh.
I just realized...
Hang on.
Do you have enough shields?
Oh, you do.
Oh my god.
Do you have enough meds for this?
No.
I'm probably dead.
I'm out of shield deals.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I think there's a rock I can sit by.
I might just Vel'Koz and go for that.
Oh.
Let's see if you make it.
I mean...
Surely I'm dead if I just stay here.
I'm out of meds.
That's true.
Yeah.
You might as well.
This is your last... your Hail Mary.
Oh my god.
It's in.
Holy fuck.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Please.
You barely won sniper shot.
No.
Oh my god.
You're not in though.
I think I can climb up a little bit.
I'm out of meds, so...
I'm gonna wait.
I'm gonna wait till the last second.
Alright.
We gotta cheese the longbow knock.
OMG.
Oh my god.
I can't believe this is happening.
You're like... you're like one shot away from dying.
There's...
Oh no!
I just hope no one looks at you.
Oh my gosh.
Do you have any heals?
No, I'm fully out.
No!
What was that?
Zeroed them.
Oh my god.
Bro, it's oof down there.
I thought I could boost her up, but it's oof and you can't boost her.
Oh my god.
One...
Two... three...
Four...
That's so joe, babe.
Five...
Seven...
Eight... I didn't know that was oof.
Honestly, that sucks.
Nine...
Did we get nine again?
We got nine.
Actually, I had to recount because we actually got ten.
I forgot to count.
We didn't use a survival item.
Oh, yeah, ten.
So it was actually ten last game, so I had to recount to make sure.
Alright.
Someone fact check me for this one?
What number you guys have?
Alright, I'll put the picture up here.
I didn't like it.
I don't even think there's any... what are the challenges?
Could I have done that game?
Just the longbow knock?
Could I have knocked somebody?
Yeah, the longbow knock...
Let's see...
We didn't have our comp last game, right?
Or did we?
No, we didn't.
We didn't.
We did this game.
Okay, so we got that.
I mean, you could have got three thousand just to keep farming.
Yeah, just a little two thousand damage.
Just a little farming.
You could have got the knock opponent off evac tower.
One player drops a 2k damage game.
Get ten kills or more as a team.
And you're the team.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're consistent.
That's...
We're improving!
It wasn't nine?
I thought it was ten.
I'm asking you guys what this game was.
Let me look at it.
Where's the board?
Alright, I'll look up too.
I thought we got ten.
I got it.
Let me look.
We got FOV, Harvesters, Backpack, Valkyrie... wait, so one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
We got ten.
I think.
That's what I came up with too.
FOV one, Harvesters two, Backpack three, Comp four, Tri-Drivel five, Nade six, Survival item seven, No Attachments eight, Alt nine.
Am I missing one?
Oh, and the heart ten.
Yeah.
Ten.
My heart.
It was the heart.
Guys.
I posted ten in our chat.
Only one other person so far got ten.
I don't know.
I feel like somebody's gonna have like twelve or fourteen or something.
Eleven.
Somebody should, realistically.
Yeah, like the last game someone got fourteen.
So I feel like someone must have got fourteen or something.
Currently it's a tiebreaker.
I wonder how they did the game one.
Cause there was like a three-way tiebreaker or something, right?
I think they did I think they just gave it to whoever won the game or was closest to winning.
The closest to winning?
What's our placement?
Um, we got We got We got Oh nevermind.
Someone got eleven.
Wait, it doesn't matter.
Someone already got eleven.
Damn.
Nooo.
What if I just edit twelve?
I guess new map.
New map time.
Hopefully a new card.
Tempo said it's new cards.
Oh, it's up.
Where?
It's up.
I look.
One red armor.
Oh my god, it's easier!
I love it!
Knock yourself with a thermite?
Okay, we can do the PVE for sure.
Is there a comp?
Do a finisher.
I'm gonna look there right now.
We need a caustic ult knock and we need get a knock with valk rockets.
300 damage with EMP.
And we need watson.
Crypto, caustic.
Crypto, caustic, and watson.
Or valk.
I'm gonna go with the watson one.
Watson is... draw a heart with watson fence.
We can just play crypto caustic.
That's so easy!
I can do that again!
And then there's rave 2.
Get the kidnap with portal.
Red armor.
We also have to take the craft cannon three times.
Oh, that's easy.
Died out of bounds?
And he did that last game.
What the fuck?
Damn, for real.
You can just sit there and spam spam with somebody.
Troach spam with opponent.
I actually need to collude with somebody.
Wait, does this mean one person can do the grab cannon thing?
Yeah, three round trip.
Does it not...
No, it just means like it means you go back and forth three times.
Oh, you do it three times?
Yeah, I'm just saying you go back and forth three times because that's a round trip.
Okay, what's the comp then?
We need... the Watson one is free, right?
Yeah.
The Crypto one's pretty free too if we live, right?
300 damage to EMP.
And then...
We can literally just like one person...
One... wait.
Does any... does...
uh...
Do they craft?
Do any of them craft?
Does Crypto or Watson have crafting for banners or no?
No.
We can just play Crypto and grab the banner and drone.
I was just thinking... Oh yeah, Crypto would, right?
No, I'm just thinking if there's crafting we can just have one person fly... literally fly outside the map and then we craft them.
I mean, realistically, it's probably just Crypto, Watson, Valk.
I'd assume... Crypto, Watson, Valk?
Yeah, we can do that.
We do Valk for the Oob as well and try to get someone with the rockets and then you can just...
Okay, so what are all the ones we can do in POI?
Noctua Therm?
Noctua PVP?
If we get a good POI.
Clear with Melee if we get a good POI.
Don't use a survival item.
The Grav Cannon's doable.
That's just one person to do that.
Yeah, the Watson Fence is doable.
Data Audubon's doable.
Ten Revive's doable.
That's pretty... it's pretty easy.
Is it like full... it's just Noct and Revive, right?
Yeah, we can literally just like PVE that.
Spam Croach with opponent?
Alright.
We can do that.
That's easy.
Ummm...
A full inventory of backpacks.
Err, sorry.
A full inventory of Bats, Blue Bag.
Use ult three times.
Wait, a full inventory of batteries?
Where's that?
The bottom.
Who's playing what?
Oh my god, that's a lot of batteries.
I can do Crypto, I suppose.
I feel like the battery thing is like almost impossible.
Yeah, well we can either play Ummm...
Err, actually I don't know.
I don't think it matters.
I don't see...
Where is the Crypto one?
Um, do 300 damage.
Do 300 damage with EMP.
Is that overall or like one EMP?
I think it's overall.
There's no way it's...
There's no way you can get that in one.
Yeah.
Like that's... I mean unless you did it at the very end of the game and like...
I mean we could just loot POI, do as many as we can, and then we just try to play UAV, Valko, to get an endgame to play the rest of the game I guess, right?
Yeah.
We just have to avoid people.
Because we're playing... I mean actually I don't know.
Hopefully we get a POI with PVE we can get two of them automatically.
Yeah.
That's easy.
True.
Do you want Valk or Crypto?
I can play either of them.
I can't play Valk so I'll do Crypto.
Alright, I'll go Valk.
And I'll draw a heart with my fences.
It's easy.
There's a P20 knock.
It's your favorite, Heemee!
Now you can have attachments to it!
Oh my god, I don't have to play on 90 of them?
Yeah!
Oh my god, I just realized.
It's a great day.
My mood has improved.
You got so much practice with the P20.
Girl, I had zero damage last game.
Okay.
What practice?
We didn't buy...
I'll shoot the spiders.
We're on Cito.
Cito.
Cito Station?
Go Station.
The new POI.
The new POI is crazy.
There's no PVE though and we're center map.
Oh, it's horrible.
We might have to just drop some of them and just play for the endgame stuff.
But we could do the Gravcan and...
Yeah, one of us has to do it though.
Not all of us have to be there.
We can do the one at our POI.
So it's three round trips like couldn't we each just take one round trip and that would be three?
If we all just took it there and back.
Wouldn't that be three round trips?
Just each of us?
It doesn't say single person.
Yeah, I think Does that count?
At the very bottom it says use ult three times one person.
Like it specifies if it's a one person challenge or a group.
So I think we technically could all just take it there and back once and be done.
Alright.
Yeah, we can do that.
Wait, the 200 damage with one frag?
We can just do that with PVE, can't we?
Can we just group all the spiders together?
Would that be 200 damage?
Do you damage points on the board?
You do, but I don't know if it means spiders or not.
I mean we also have to do PVE with melee only, so...
Yeah... I mean if we get the one melee off...
Oh, is it all PVE as melee?
Or...
Clear PVE with melee.
So it has to be all melee.
We have to clear it, but that's like one spider.
Yeah, we have to fight with people for the PVE.
But I could throw one nade at like a Prowler and get the bottom one.
200 damage maybe?
I think it would do 200 though.
I don't know.
I guess we just have to make sure somebody's holed up somewhere and then just throw a nade.
Yeah, for like a whole team.
Yeah.
Hmm...
Hey, now it's one red army.
Wait, we weren't winning though.
How did someone got 14?
I mean last game somebody got 14 as well.
It's the same person.
Are they just duping challenges?
It's the same person that got last one as well.
That's crazy.
They got for game two.
I wonder what they did to like hit all of that so fast.
They probably just did the early ones and then had a good game honestly.
Yeah, but they get two in a row?
They're so lucky!
Xenox, why aren't you as lucky as Amu?
It's just impossible to get lucky.
Guys, we have three more games.
Guys, three more.
It's okay.
We don't make it to finals.
That means we have another chance in the other two tournaments.
We're playing the long game here guys.
Guys, just think.
We're playing the long game.
Do you think it's still worth it if we get a good zone and we just rotate to it?
We don't want to do...
We just do the ones in the building and play for like the damage and stuff?
We don't want to go to the finals yet so we can do the other tournaments.
Yeah.
It's like the booster one.
It would take a long time.
It's the long con!
It's the long con.
Trust the process.
I'll make it to the finals.
I'll make it to the finals on the last tournament.
All of us.
Where are my pod clips guys?
We should just do it and then camp it.
Oh my gosh.
We're camping the cannons?
No, I'd be evil though.
Oh shit.
No, we should.
Finish your grab challenge and then just camp it.
Yeah, no.
We should totally do that.
It's the plan.
Even before the crypto fucking scans us though.
I feel like you're gonna throw a crypto drone at us.
Wait, you guys sent a clip!
You guys sent a clip!
There's one clip!
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
Why is it dead?
I'm sending this.
This is my one clip I'm sending.
Because that's the only clip I have.
I'm gonna write the only clip my chat was willing to link the clip.
Putting that in there.
That is the only clip you guys did.
I can't believe it.
Guys!
We need actual clips!
It's gonna be voted!
Guys!
This is going to be voted on!
We need actual clips!
I'm busy editing another one.
Guys, I swear to fucking god.
This is... Oh shit!
Good!
Okay, here we go.
Wait, I'm gonna look at this clip.
I'm watching this.
Oh my god.
It's the fucking screen.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, I'm posting that one too.
It's okay.
We're gonna game the system.
If we have enough...
No, we can't have too many clips, guys!
We can't...
Guys, I know my clips are off, but like...
Guys...
It is...
Guys, okay, here's the plan.
We want that thousand dollars.
That...
Having clips off should not stop us from this.
Maybe we just get a crazy zone and we can just sit in zone with the other zombies.
If you're passionate enough, it will not stop you.
There you go.
Us, guys!
This is a team effort!
Everyone, team effort!
Crypto can scan for enemies at least.
Yeah.
Only it's one.
It's one EMP, so you're gonna have to hit like a...
Multiple team EMP, I think.
Okay.
I'll try.
Hopefully we just get...
Wait, it's one EMP?
Like, he said it was one?
Zero said it was one EMP and mine said yes.
Oh...
Okay, that's like end zone shit right there.
You might be able to land on the beacon and hit it twice for double evo.
You should be able to, actually, depending on the timing.
Am I pinging?
That's weird.
Or is... Oh, hey, see?
Hey, we have...
We have beacon!
Isn't double evo anymore?
Oh, that's not...
I'm so sorry.
I'm gonna loot out here and loot in.
Someone can loot the big building and then...
And this, and someone just get the middle and stuff.
I'll get the middle and stuff.
I'll do here.
Okay.
Are you not landing on the beacon?
Wait, am I... I don't think you can anymore, apparently.
Watson can't...
Wait, do I land on the beacon?
No, you're the beacon.
Oh, shit!
Okay, guys, sorry.
You should be able to hit it twice for double evo.
So I'll do here, I'll do here then.
I got confused this scans.
See, this is why I'm the content creator.
I don't remember who does what.
I'll do one...
Wait, can you not do twice anymore?
I guess not.
That's what someone said.
If I'm believing him.
Oh, okay.
I won't do it then.
I don't believe him.
We were hitting it twice.
Oh, okay.
No, no, just wait.
I don't trust.
We got good zone.
Oh my god, we did.
I think we might just play zone this game.
I'm not gonna lie.
Because we just get in, we can do all of them for free.
I'm already hearing some stuff behind me.
Wait, should have said that you should know.
You're clearly a pro player.
How do you not know?
Well, they updated it.
And then they reverted the patch.
And I don't know when they fixed it.
I'm gonna hit this Evo.
If I find a thermite, I'm just gonna do the thermite.
I don't think we have extra.
I know.
There's no Evo harvester level.
There's no.
Nope.
I didn't see one.
I just crafted bat and then we're gonna go zone.
We can get a good spot here.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
There's an R9 here.
Oh, that's a carbine.
Oh, I thought it was a thermite.
Nevermind.
Let's go.
Do I get the revive or the fallen stars?
Honestly, I don't even know.
Let's run up on this hill.
And I can vocal.
We gotta melee these.
Let's just play for the challenges.
Let's go melee these spiders.
And then do we let someone die to them?
Yeah.
Wait, there's a thermite here.
I'm gonna do...
Yeah, I'm gonna down myself now.
Let's wait till we get to the building and the spiders.
Make sure we don't get pushed.
Oh, okay.
I'll do the pylon.
Oh, wait.
You can do your heart in this building too if you'd like.
Yeah, let's get to the building.
There's a care package on this too.
This is really good.
Let's do the PvE last.
You can knock yourself with the thermite in the building.
And do the hearts.
And then we can get the care package and do the PvE stuff.
Alright.
I'll do the hearts.
Wait, I'll knock myself first?
And then do the...
Or someone else can knock themselves.
It doesn't matter.
Whoever is... just drop your armor and knock yourself.
I'm just gonna start doing the hearts now.
Okay.
Alright, we got the res.
Yep.
Thank you.
This is not a heart.
Okay.
Let's do the melee PvE.
And then one person...
Wait, actually...
The melee PvE and then one person should die to the spiders.
That's not a heart.
Oh, come on.
That is such a heart.
There you go.
That has to be a heart.
That's like half a heart.
Wait, no.
Like if you think... Yes, it is.
You look at like this direction.
Yes, that's a heart.
I'm not getting heart from this at all.
Come on.
Punch these out.
Somebody help me punch these out.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's a heart.
I can redo it.
You work on that another time.
No, no.
You work on that.
I'm gonna go melee.
Okay, okay, wait.
Okay.
Can you keep an eye and make sure nobody walks up while we're doing this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna let them kill me too.
Let them get me low.
Let this one get me low.
Let it kill me.
I'm looking around right now and I'm also making my heart.
I need to go aggro these spiders.
Can they aimbot me?
Oh my god, they're just missing.
This is taking forever.
Wait, I thought you were gonna... Just make sure we don't get walked up on.
I'm trying to make sure right now while I make this heart.
Okay, kill the rest and then answer resume.
Okay, there you go.
Heart.
Alright.
Just make sure nobody pulls up on us.
We can punch up for us.
Okay, I'm gonna punch these.
Can I get a medkit?
I don't have one.
I dropped a headband kit.
Yeah, we did it.
Let's go.
Can we do the grav cannon here maybe?
Yeah, look at this.
Heart, heart, heart, heart.
Look at it.
Definitely a heart.
So, do we figure out how much we have to do this actually?
Or do we all just take it twice?
We all take it back and forth once.
We all take it there and back.
Let me take it first just in case.
Make sure there's nobody there.
Okay, we're good.
You can take it.
We did it.
We can grab the EVO harvester and then we're gonna...
On platform.
On the platform of...
Okay, take it back.
Take it back.
And then we're done.
We're done.
We can take it later.
We did it.
Can you hit this UAV with your drone?
There's a team over here so we just...
I'm grabbing this EVO harvester.
Alright.
There's a team above on the rock by the way.
God Rock.
Let's just hit UAV with drone.
And then we're gonna play in the barometer.
They're hitting UAV right now.
If they push us, we have to go back to the building and hold it and fight them.
How do I hit this shit?
You just press E on it.
Nice.
How do I hit this shit?
That's not right.
E.
There we go.
Let's go back to the building.
Let's go.
We're gonna go to get up here.
We're gonna take out from them.
I'm 500 away from getting the red EVO.
Holy shit.
A lot of people are like...
I guess cause they're not getting back out of the ground.
I honestly think we could just go get in the zone and have a good game.
Yeah we can.
Let's play for top barometer and hit the UAV up there and then we'll valk ult in the zone.
Alright.
There is a barometer team so we might have to...
Can we valk into it?
Yeah we're gonna valk ult up here.
I have like...
2, 4, 6... I have 6 bats.
I have 6 bats.
Do you guys have a lot of bats on you?
I know.
They're rising right now.
Come come come.
I'm right behind.
I'm here.
Pop your evac on the roof.
Are we gonna use our survival item?
Oh yeah true.
Is that one of them?
Don't use any.
You might as well just drop them.
That's a survival item.
I don't see it on this card.
Oh it is.
Sorry I'm stupid.
I'm sorry.
There might be a team riding in the zone.
Let's get this out of here.
Just be careful.
We're going or not.
There's a team over there.
No team.
Can you hit the UAV and barometer with your run again?
Yep.
Is there any way we can die to uber on here?
I don't know if we're gonna be able to do that actually.
Cause we'd have to use our mobi to res.
I mean you have the crypto drone to just fly to mobile res.
Yeah but there aren't many in the zone.
There's one here.
Let's hit the beacon.
We might be able to just get a good spot in zone soon.
I'm watching it.
Yeah.
Let's just go play up here.
Let's go.
There is someone up on the hill so.
Crouch spam.
If they are.
We can get the crouch.
Yeah we gotta get the crouch.
We're probably gonna go to the left.
I just wanna see if there's any.
Is anybody up here actually holding it?
They're on my scan no?
Yeah but I think they're third party.
They're in the open right here.
Oh.
Want me to shoot?
Or let them walk?
Can we shoot?
No let's just go to the corner.
Whoa.
Careful.
Let's go quick.
We can stay here with Jhin.
Oh somebody.
And then do we have a lot of nades?
We could do the down 10 times thing in the corner.
Ummm.
I only have two.
I have two nades on me.
We have how many reses?
We have one res only right?
We have two.
I died as well.
Close to me.
Close to me right here.
Can you kill him?
I see him.
Oh.
You can get a gen down.
We're gonna play this whole corner area.
Okay I'll put a gen here.
And then just get fences up on our back.
Yeah.
Careful.
There's water here.
Whoa.
You can come back here.
You're full safe back here.
No my gen.
He's in the tower.
Just crouch.
I'm literally being grief from everywhere.
Jesus.
I'm batting her hair.
Well.
Revive number 3.
I hear a bloodhound ult.
Okay.
They're walking up.
Yeah.
One is behind the rock.
I can't see them right now.
I'm healing up.
I'm fine.
You're full safe behind the trees back here.
Okay.
I'm just fencing up for us.
Yeah you're good.
You're good.
We could just keep getting knocked to that tower, Tzim.
For the knocks.
Yeah but that gives them...
You can play back here.
Play back on me.
Yeah play back on me.
I'll wait for my ult and then we can play ult here.
Depending on next zone we might just valk all and go better spot.
We're just kinda waiting for Zona to pull.
Does anyone have a med kit or a white house?
I can give you two syringes.
That's it though.
Is there anyone you can look for?
We need two teams to do the EMP thing, huh?
Yeah we do.
Oh there's a team across from us.
Yeah.
That's where they are?
You can just sit behind these for now.
Whoa!
Should be okay.
I'm okay.
No my baby.
I got the red armor one.
Nice we got red armor.
Nice.
I have...
Let's play back on me.
Sorry I'm slowly retreading my shield.
I was trying to think if we could just valk up into a spot but...
Gosh this team.
This team is very annoying.
It's one team holding all of Coastal.
Bro I can't...
I only have one shield cell left.
I can give you some.
Yeah I'm using my last cells right now.
I'm good.
I can regen my shields.
I'm gonna drop a couple and I'm gonna go push this guy off of us.
We're just chillin.
This is our home for now.
Are they fighting down the hill?
We might third party down the hill if they fight.
Cause there's a team up here.
They're gonna come shoot us in the back.
Put it here.
Are there anything else?
We try and get some eyes on this.
There really isn't much to look for.
We live in the bamboos.
There's a team down here so we gotta be careful.
If you can see, if there's two teams playing on each other you can EMP them for the thing.
I know I was trying to look.
Is there a team walking up the hill from my self 207?
One team?
Full team here?
I have...
Should I save my Watson gen or use it now?
Honestly I'm not sure.
Is this... I think you wait a little bit.
I think you wait a little bit.
We have to play like just loose for now until people...
Is it flying?
Is it flying over us?
We can look to kill them maybe.
They're gonna land in between the team.
I'm gonna hit the... I'm gonna hit the big nade here.
Might be the 200 damage nade.
Break the gen.
Gen's broken.
I'm right side.
I'm being shot too.
Yeah yeah this team... I have no heals guys.
I'm literally gonna get knocked too.
I'm looking at our right at the moment.
Keep...
No what?
Oh I might be dead to this too.
I have to use... yeah I'm dead to this.
I got shot from a team to the right here.
They might push.
Oh no no they got it.
They got ulted.
Oh okay goodbye.
I mean I was safe!
I can come back.
I'm gonna wait and see if they're pushing.
So many teams here.
They're running off the hill.
You're dead.
What do you mean?
There's a team coming up the hill right here.
You could have gotten this res.
You could have easily res this.
What other challenges... are there any other challenges?
We've got red armor.
We've got knock.
One two three.
Let me look.
Let me look since I'm fucking dead.
Have you knocked anyone with your bow crockets?
You could go for that.
I'll try to do that this game.
You could go for...
A finisher.
A 360 no scope with a sniper.
There's a sniper.
A finisher.
I could craft you and res.
Should I try to res you guys right here for fun?
It counts as two res's now.
Yeah.
But is that...
Sure.
There might be a team still there.
But sure.
There's so many teams back here.
I don't know how you could care.
I'm gonna say...
If you can get a big ass nade.
Like a frag nade.
200 damage.
I would just try for those two.
I'm gonna go for the bow crockets.
You've used your ult three times right?
Have we?
Ooh.
Um.
I think you used it two times.
Not three.
Yeah I'm gonna use it one more time.
Oh there they come.
Okay what else?
I think that's it.
Unless you see a trident driving by.
What was the trident for?
Stick em with an arc star.
Oh.
Wait crouch spamming.
You can crouch spam and hopefully crouch spam back.
Before they kill you.
Yeah since you are a rat that would be funny.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Before...
Maybe I just run up on em and crouch spam.
Okay but like not now.
Yeah do it three in.
It's okay.
If they AD spam you that's a crouch spam.
That's a crouch spam.
That counts.
Oh shit.
That's one.
You're so fucked if they push you in front of you.
Okay I mute myself.
Cause I don't want to distract him.
Cause he's like super focused right now.
Someone come crouch spam with me.
This would have been amazing to play as Watson right here.
No it counts cause like...
No.
They're dodging your bullets by crouch spamming.
So it counts sort of.
I'm just gonna crouch spam for the rest of the game.
And pray that someone kills me as crouching.
Make sure you get your Valkyrie knock first.
With your Q.
Yeah.
There's a full team right behind you.
Yeah I hear them right over here.
It's okay.
Maybe they'll be crouched too.
Find another rat.
Oh you're in the middle of the zone.
That is not good.
I might just Valk all when I get it.
For 2% and just get the point.
We need one more right?
I've used it twice.
Yeah you only used it twice.
You didn't use it a third time.
You might as well parry this.
They don't know.
Wait but where would you go?
Oh shit.
I can't go anywhere.
At least you can see where everybody is.
Wait.
Land on top of the silo.
Could be safe.
Well now you can't land on top.
Oh.
Go crouch spam.
Maybe they'll be good to you.
Look if they crouch once.
That's considered a crouch spam.
Oh yeah.
Nice.
Just live there.
Jesus Christ.
How many teams are there?
That's a lot.
Oh.
No.
No time.
You tried.
Shit.
Didn't even give you the chance.
You should have spammed harder.
It was so close.
How many do we have?
Let's see.
I'm not sure.
This one seemed a lot harder to spam.
One, two, three, four.
Uh...
I think we have six.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
I think we only have seven?
Yeah melee knock.
Does the melee knock consider with PvE?
I don't think it...
I think the melee knock has to be on a player.
Oh seven.
Seven.
We have seven.
Eight.
Seven.
Wait what are the eight?
We have eight.
One, two...
Eight.
Yeah.
I don't think that's a winner.
There's no way.
I feel like more teams got eight.
The highest in there is eight so far.
Yeah but there's still teams alive.
I'm pretty sure teams alive are the ones that are gonna have the...
uh... the most.
Maybe we go back in the VOD and I was crouch spamming and someone else across the map was crouch spamming.
You know what?
I'm pretty sure that happened.
You know when you were wingmanning that one team that was under the bridge?
They were crouch spamming?
They were crouch spamming.
They were trying to dodge your bullets.
That's a nine.
We're not gonna win but it's like the message.
I feel like that's what we had done earlier.
There's the get knocked ten time one.
The ten revive one still teams six at a time.
Well I feel like the out of bounds one we could have done.
Easily.
Yeah true the out of bounds one.
Ten revives and out of bounds ones we could do.
In the crotch of the opponent.
I put us as nine because I counted the crotch spam.
We're not gonna win anyways.
Just the message overall.
Just
the message overall.
I mean we could easily do the revive outside of zone.
Yeah we could hug zone and just keep rezzing?
Yeah we could have done that.
Or like just be at the edge of zone and then just revive.
We can do this next game.
Knock revive at the edge of zone.
Red armor is doable.
Thermite doable.
DVE is doable.
No survival items doable.
Grav cannon doable.
Yeah we just in this next game we need to do this.
We have to do the die to bounce and rev to the redstone.
So we have to sit in zone and heal.
Yeah.
I think we get bad if we have a bad POI and a bad like zone.
We can do that.
Yeah we can just do edge.
That should be easy.
Same comp or?
Do we keep the valk?
I feel like the crypto is like mid.
I don't think we play for the crypto EMP.
It's kinda high so I'm not gonna lie.
That's too hard to do.
What else could help you guys?
We need to do the...
We're doing watson for the fence.
We could play...
Let's see.
Because the fence was super easy.
I mean we could do wraith.
The portal was...
Or caustic.
I think caustic is nice.
Either one.
I think caustic is good for zone control.
Yeah with that plus watson we'd be like locked down.
Yeah people can't push us as easily.
I'm done.
Do we do valk just to get in the zone?
Because we're gonna be sitting in zone dying 10 times.
Yeah we can do valk, caustic and watson.
Are there any support characters we can play?
So we can craft banner and rise an oob without having to use a mobi?
Yeah like a conduit or loba.
We'll have to get rid of one.
Lifeline could help with the revives.
We can't get rid of watson because we need watson for the thing.
We could play lifeline for the red armor if you want.
Instead of caustic.
Because it gives you a cash on first place.
And the revives.
I could do lifeline.
Zero got 14 so...
We were never gonna get close.
We were second!
Technically.
If they don't have another 9.
Yeah zero's team got 14.
I'm pretty sure they were like end game or something.
Damn if we were game 3 with second we could have advanced to the finals.
Let's see.
What else is there?
I don't know.
Let's do the battery one.
If we play edge.
Lifeline is good for the battery one actually.
Don't you get a ton of bats in the back?
Oh yeah.
Lifeline, watson, what's the third?
Valk for the rotation.
Valk I think.
Yeah sure.
And then you have the rockets.
This tournament is pretty difficult.
These challenges are hard.
I think the hardest part chat right now is just remembering the challenges.
I'm just like what's in the challenges again?
It's so difficult to remember.
I'm just listening to what they tell me to do.
I'm like I don't know.
I don't even know what the challenges are.
I'm just like okay.
I'll just exist.
Oh wait nice.
Okay this is a good clip.
Good guys.
Thank you guys for clipping it.
If we can't win the...
I'm just like okay.
If we can't win the fucking...
The tournament itself.
We will win the clips challenge.
We will win the clips challenge instead.
I put the goodbye you're dead.
I put that clip in there.
We gotta get this W somewhere.
I
can't believe I got that.
I got left for dead.
Wait Tempo is running scrims at the same time as this tournament?
No what?
No wonder he has seven monitors.
I just realized.
He's running the fucking...
Apex pro scrims.
The same time as this fucking tournament.
I saw him posted like here are the scores.
From today's scrims.
I was like wait a minute.
There's a tournament going on.
I'm not even being here.
The scores are today's scrims.
Oh my god.
No wonder.
For those who don't know.
Tempo runs the pro team scrims in Apex Legends.
So not only is he running this tournament.
But he's also running the scrims at the same time.
So it makes sense why he has seven monitors.
He is definitely multitasking right now.
He is running.
We just need to stack white men's then when we're looting.
Cause we're looting.
Cause we're probably gonna have to go sit in zone for the whole game.
To be able to get all of it.
Cause if we sit in zone.
We get the out of bounds as well.
We get the revives.
We get the extra bats.
And then that's just an extra three from what we had this last game.
Yeah.
We have crafting right?
So one of us can fly out of bounds.
Yeah you can just die instantly.
Yeah so we can get that point instantly.
Yeah we just play for support bins for the bats.
Oh my god guys.
Guys.
I just realized.
He added the melee.
Remember when I told him to add a knockout with punch?
He actually added it.
We contributed to the tournament.
Look.
Where is it?
Get a melee knock.
We contributed to the card.
I actually wrote that to him.
We did it.
If we don't win anything.
At least we had something on the card.
We helped guys.
All of us helped together.
This is a group effort of contribution right there.
Nice.
Achievement.
I contributed to the tournament.
Wait what's our POI?
They are doing it right now.
Oh okay.
Okay.
I can't believe this team got 13.
We would have been like...
We are second.
0-1 before.
I can't believe it.
We were so close.
We are doing our part.
Guys we have so many clips.
Guys we are fucking drowning clips right now.
Everybody said one.
But I have three.
I am deleting the meow one.
I am deleting it.
I am deleting that.
This is not going to be on our record.
Because now we have more clips.
I am going to delete the cat one.
That's not professional.
That is not professional.
No we are not keeping it.
Nobody is going to vote for it.
Guys.
The votes are happening in girls discord.
You are not in her discord.
Her fans are going to be voting for it.
I am going to be so confused.
Because the vote...
Don't raid her discord by the way.
Do not raid her discord.
It has no gameplay.
No.
Guys we are not rigging the vote.
We are not rigging the vote.
We have to give good content.
We have the worst giveaway we can get.
Oh man.
We have to have good content.
Wait but that is good for PvE though.
Isn't it?
There is no PvE there anymore.
Wait no.
No.
What is the point?
We have the cannons.
I think we are going to just have to loot the POI.
And thread the needle.
And make it to like a PvE.
And just avoid teams.
And work our way out of the zone.
If we want to do the challenges.
Let me see.
Alright.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
We will be fine.
I believe in this.
Maybe like the zone is like.
So far from us.
Maybe.
So it will be fine.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe.
I can't believe they removed the fucking.
Uh.
This is why I am the content creator.
Exactly.
This is exactly why.
I am the content creator.
I didn't even remember.
Where the fuck the.
I didn't even remember the new map does not have PvE anymore.
I am the content creator of this team.
It is fine.
Respect.
We are not putting Nia back.
It's not going to win us anything.
Guys.
The only reason you wanted there is because you wanted to show on girl stream.
And that is why I am exactly taking it out.
This is exactly why I took out that clip.
Because I am not having that clip show up on stream.
It will.
Okay.
If I put that clip back.
And we don't win.
You guys owe me.
Somewhere.
I will get that thousand dollars.
Holy.
I will get that.
Somewhere.
Okay all right.
All right.
I will put it back in.
Just for you guys.
Okay.
Where the fuck is it?
Did you guys delete it?
Oh no no.
It's still there.
I just went by it.
Slight change in two of the challenges.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, slight change.
Because it caused too much revives.
Oh, there's no more revives.
Win a game with less than 1500 damage.
Which other one did he change?
And get a knock with a Mozambique.
Win a game with less than 1500...
Okay, that's so fucking specific.
So I guess we don't have to be in zone all game.
That's actually better for Jurassic, I guess.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, I'm putting back the clip, guys.
I'm putting it back, guys.
Just for you guys, I'm putting it back.
You need that.
Easy.
That's actually big for us.
Okay, guys.
I don't know if you guys noticed, but it says win a game.
Oh, win.
Oh, wait a minute.
Wait, that's impossible.
Yeah, I'm just saying.
I'm just saying.
Let me calm down.
Yeah.
I don't...
The closest we got was when Xenox got us both killed and got it for it.
It's okay.
This...
At least, you know, we can get the Mozambique, I think.
I think that'll work.
I don't know.
This is gonna be weird.
We have to pray there's PB we can get to.
Wait, who's gonna do the Mozambique then?
Whoever gets one.
Whoever gets the Mozambique does the Mozambique.
I think no one's ever gonna fucking drive the Trident.
Unless you're like, colluding with a team and was like, hey, can you get on it?
We can exchange Tridents.
Same with the crouch spamming.
It was hard.
They just instantly killed everyone.
You go to crouch spam on someone, you just kill them.
Yeah, but some of them crouch spam to dodge bullets.
So you both crouch spam to dodge bullets.
It's considered crouch spamming.
There's that.
I hate being social.
I will be an introvert forever.
No!
I spilled my bubble tea.
I was trying to pee.
This is like me for real.
No!
I squeezed too much air.
I did it again!
Fuck!
Okay.
Let me wipe this off real fast.
I have a little...
I have...
I'm a mess.
I'm dropping everything.
I'm a fucking mess right now.
Okay.
Not my bubble tea.
An extrovert is not worth it.
It's not.
Let me just fix this real fast.
Fix this.
Alright.
It looks like it's stay as locked in.
I don't have to worry about This is game two.
Swapping.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm just...
Make sure... I'm already on Watson.
I don't have to worry.
Yeah!
Don't have to worry.
Alright.
Make sure I unmute myself.
Here we go.
We got beacon.
I guess the...
There might be a universe where we just go to zone because there's no resing ones anymore.
Wait.
Are we not gonna fly off the map?
They got rid of it.
Oh, they got rid of flying off the map?
Oh no!
There's no UUB one either, right?
Yeah, no.
They're gone.
I'm just gonna line close and line close.
Somebody do the...
I'll go over here.
I'll go do this.
One person loot this and then beacon and bunker and stuff.
Well, if you're not going in the back, I'll land in the back and look my way.
I can do it.
I'm gonna go to the tunnel.
I'm gonna do the tunnel.
Oh, I have a thermite.
I can do it right now.
The thermite.
Oh, wait.
Actually, no.
I have to wait for you guys.
I'll come revive you.
Yeah, give me a second.
Yeah, no.
It's fine.
I'll just wait until you're closer.
And then I'll do the thermite.
Cool, cool, cool.
I got one of the nades... not nades.
Bats we need.
Same.
Alright.
Scanning.
Scanning now.
Alright.
I'm gonna run...
I'm just gonna run...
repeater... well...
Let me know when you're done...
downloading.
You can just come...
come onto the tunnel when you're done.
Should we take the...
We can try to do the PV.
You can do the booster on you really quick if you want.
Yeah, I was gonna say we can do the cannon.
I'm gonna... you guys... I'm gonna grab this EVO really quick so we lose.
I'm gonna do the thermite right now.
And then you can give me the...
the... the suck.
Alright.
I'm doing it.
Oh, I got the crouch spam with this guy.
Should I be a bastard?
No!
Do it!
Who cares?
Oh, I might die.
What happened?
She just did her thermite.
Yeah, her thermite.
Oh, I thought there was a team on us.
Yeah, no, no.
I was doing my thermite.
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
I need the suck now.
Have you done the booster yet?
Actually, I don't know.
We shouldn't do this one.
The pylon team is gonna kill us.
Let's go up here.
What is the booster one exactly?
Oh, here's a Mozamm.
We just hit the... we have to hit the crab cannon.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm dropping the senti if anyone wants to get a no scope knock with it.
I'm doing the Mozamm right now.
Let's go up here.
Oh, you're doing Mozamm?
Okay.
I'm here.
We might be able to do this crab cannon.
I'm not sure.
It's kind of risky.
It's sent him out.
It's an airdrop over here.
We should play for this.
There was a team over here, so we might have to fight for it.
Oh, man.
Maybe they won't have blue armor.
Maybe they're still white armor.
Are we not gonna do the cannon?
I wanna get the package because we can get red off of it.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna hold right here.
Someone...
There's a team out here.
Just play these rocks and someone watch behind us.
I'll watch the back.
You should grab the EVO thing on Lifeline.
And then you can take your care package.
We can get double care package guns.
Okay.
Will I get it when I get this?
If there's an EVO cache in it.
Just do it with luck.
Nice.
Okay.
And then take your...
purple gun.
Or the care package gun one.
And then we can get another.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then the upgrade that gives you the care package.
Lifeline upgrade.
Oh, sorry.
I was like, wait.
What are you talking about?
I looked in the care package.
All I have is... I have gift.
Next ult is a play drop or gain self revive.
That one.
The first one.
I'm gonna take it and scout it.
Make sure there's nobody there.
We're not gonna do this one.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my heart!
I don't see anybody.
All right.
Do I take it?
I'm gonna take it.
Yeah.
Just give me to take it back.
And then...
You have to take it too.
Yeah.
I already took it the one time.
I just stopped halfway.
All right.
I've done my double.
So it's up to...
Just take it back and come back to me.
I'm not even gonna take it.
I can just take it and it'll be six.
Okay.
That's six.
Let's go for the PvE up here.
I need to drop my ult.
I'm gonna die.
You might have to take it back.
Take it back.
We can craft him later.
Just go craft me.
There is a crafter not close to us at all.
You can play for cascade.
Just play slow and play for cascade.
I'll go back to cascade then.
Yeah.
Just play cascade.
Just play slow.
That's unlucky.
I'm just gonna run to cascade first.
And if I die, you don't go to cascade.
Or just one of us.
I feel like...
It's best if I just scout ahead.
Because then you can just rez both of us if I die.
Yeah.
That's much more easier.
So I'll just go up first.
Because like...
I feel like you're gonna get pushed though.
You can rez on the...
We might rez on the...
Spider Troke.
The spider one.
Because we can do the spiders after.
I'll go craft and you head to the spider.
You go to the spider first.
I think there's a team there.
There's a team near me.
So I'll just grab you now.
You might have to get me on the waterfall.
I'm just gonna grab you now.
So if I die, you might as well just craft.
Like I'm gonna go the other way.
Maybe the one on your right.
There's a fight to my left.
I'm just gonna go straight to the...
Don't go to the spider Troke.
Go to Dokie.
Sorry, I picked up who you were speaking to.
It's okay.
Alright, here I go.
We might get pushed though.
Probably gonna get pushed.
You can rez me and just run away if you want.
Also, I don't want Hini to be close to me then.
He just heard somebody.
No, okay.
We could do the spiders in front of us.
Yeah, I'm gonna look command center when I rez in.
If there's nobody up there, you just both run up there.
Are they here?
You should be good to go command center.
I don't see anybody yet.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna shoot the spiders then.
We gotta let one of them knock us too.
Knock one.
They could still be up there so be careful.
I need to lose my guns.
Yeah, I'm just gonna do one first.
I'm just gonna do one.
I'm just bad at melee.
Huh?
There's the last one.
You're punching them, yeah?
Yeah, I'm punching them.
I'm just doing one at a time and then just let it knock somebody.
I'm just doing one at a time because I don't wanna risk it.
Yeah, wait for me.
Alright, I'm just gonna heal up.
There's the last one.
There's one more.
I'll do it.
Let it...
Let it kill me, I'm lost.
This is going to take forever.
Just make sure nobody pulls up while we're doing this.
I'm going to look up.
I'm looking top.
Someone look bottom.
I hear a car below.
There's a car here.
Go shoot them.
Shoot that car back on the north.
Hit it with an arc.
I'll try.
Where is it?
Coming up the hill.
Oh, that way.
Okay.
Bro, can these spiders shoot me?
They're hiding behind something.
So they are aggroing me.
I'm hiding.
These spiders are like brain dead.
Just instantly left handers me and punched them out.
Yeah, I know.
I just couldn't stay close because...
I'm looking at top still.
They're literally just missing on me.
That's so unfortunate.
Team below.
Oh no!
Really?
Can you shoot them?
The team below?
Are they walking up?
I can't tell.
We're good.
I'm going to risk it.
Okay.
Just kill me.
Hurry up.
Please.
Just shoot down the hill.
Shoot down here.
Res me.
Yeah.
I got the spider.
I can go res.
I'll res.
Just heal.
I threw a drone already.
We have to run.
They're going to push us.
I don't have fucking shit.
We have all... We have all... We cleared the spiders.
We cleared it.
Okay.
Let's run.
Get up top.
Come on.
I threw a drone already.
Sorry.
I was totally prepared to.
I just want to... I don't want to die to them.
It's okay.
I have a phoenix kit for you.
Yeah.
I'll grab it when we get up here.
Wait.
Did you call the package?
Oh.
You did already, right?
I did.
Yeah.
Okay.
Can I get the phoenix?
Here you go.
I'm just going to watch behind us and... really quick.
Im a lot looking front.
Okay.
They're not coming.
Yeah.
We'll make sure there's nobody in front of us, though.
I'm gonna...
I'm going to...
I'm here for... I just put this in here.
Except that's on my right.
Okay.
Left.
Left of me.
Okay.
Come back if you have to.
We're just going to wait here till Zunklo's.
Alright.
I'm looking at the door.
I need a scrap loot because I don't have anything.
I can give you meds here.
Here's chillots.
I can give you syringes though.
I'm gonna scan.
I can give you syringes.
I have some.
Can we hit beacon?
I need a sentinel.
Holy fuck.
Circle is far.
Mmmmm.
Come this way.
I might zip up and see if there's anybody up there.
Wait, there's a sniper here.
Did you grab the sniper?
Yeah you did.
I'm just looking for a sentinel.
There might be a team riding up top.
If there is, then I'm gonna drop.
I will not be surprised.
I can put fences at the bottom too.
Yeah, put a bunch of fences up.
If I drop, just lifeline res.
They're gonna drop so you have to get ready to insta kill them once you lifeline res me.
Yeah.
Wait, I have to make a hard still.
Fuck.
Yeah, you can do that.
Yeah, you need to.
The moment you come... there's nobody above, right?
I don't know yet.
I'm just waiting.
Are you still... oh my god, you're still...
Wait, can we hit the beacon again?
I can... Yeah, I can.
They're here but they're out here.
Okay, I can try.
Okay.
We don't have to.
Yeah, if you don't want to.
I just want to wait until all of us are together.
You can come up here.
Okay, I'm gonna make the hard.
I'm gonna make the hard.
I'm coming up.
Can you do it up here?
They're on the door.
We're gonna just Velc ult out of the top of command.
I'm gonna make the hard, guys.
Give me a sec.
Yeah, go for it.
They're on the door.
They could be riding inside so just be careful.
I don't think they are though.
I need to wait.
I don't have enough seconds.
I fucked up.
I'm coming back quick.
I fucked up with my offenses.
Careful, they were on the door.
I need one more.
Seven seconds and then I can make my hard.
We need to make sure they don't come from over here.
How many bats do we have?
Do we have enough to do the bat thing?
Nope, I have one.
I only have two.
Come over here.
I'm gonna see if they're up here or not.
I'm with you.
They might have left.
Coming back.
I made my hard.
They're still all the way back.
Bullet's flying.
Is that a third or?
No, it's the same team.
We're gonna valk out of the top.
Hello?
We just have to slam a spot and pray that it's open.
I'm praying for you.
Here?
Whoa.
This is spooky.
I'm gonna go back.
There's definitely a team here.
I saw some shots.
Shots from here.
There's a team there.
There's a team here.
There's a... oh ho ho.
We're slamming the back of this.
We have to instantly get a gen down, okay?
They're gonna push us.
Got gen?
Nice.
Just hold.
I got a bat.
Papa ult yourself.
You have one.
No, I don't.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to take damage.
Yeah.
How is this hitting us?
Oh my gosh, my...
Do you have drone?
Any drone right here?
I just threw it.
I threw it already.
Nice.
Whoa, how is that still?
It's fine.
We're good.
There you go.
This is very scuffed, but like...
Do we have any ulti-excells?
Yeah, I'm gonna redo the fences now.
Pop that ulti-excell for...
For Watson drone.
Careful, he's like hard starting.
I know, I know.
I'm trying to redo this...
Our fences.
He's gonna do it.
Yeah.
Yeah!
No!
What other...
What other challenges do we have to do?
Mosem knock.
Win a game with less damage.
A finisher.
Melee knock.
360.
Okay, so we should just play to win the game at this point.
We should just play to win the game at this point.
We need the melee finisher.
360.
I am Mozambique longbow.
I have the goat loadout right now.
They're throwing bows up on us.
Do you have Watson drone?
You can pop this.
You can get Watson drone if you want.
Are you close to red armor?
I'm 44 right now.
Should I pop it?
I feel like we get it.
How much you off red armor?
224.
You should try to poke a little bit and try to get it.
Because it's a free point if we get it.
Just be careful.
Maybe we just have to wait.
I think we might have to wait.
I'm really okay.
I'm going to pop my ulti now.
I don't think we can get it in time.
Oh my god.
You got this.
I believe in you.
You're not 90 FOV anymore.
There's a body out here.
I'm going to try to loot this body.
There's a Mozambique on it.
This is an area.
I can connect here.
Nice.
It looks great.
I'll take this away.
And then...
Connect you here.
Does anyone have another gun I can have?
What's your other gun?
I have a vault in 30-30.
You can have the wingman.
I have longbow Mozambique.
I'll take the Mozambique.
Don't we need the longbow for a knock?
No, it's sentinel.
Back that on us.
Just play in the corner.
They'll take it.
They'll die.
Don't overpeek.
Don't worry.
I'm safe.
We need to get a finish on that.
Oh, Hemi, be careful.
Oh, that's mine.
You're fine.
We're fine.
I am fine in this little corner.
I'm batting.
Safe on A.
Yeah, I'm safe too.
We can't get a finish on that?
Nope.
No, we can't.
I'll flank down here.
I don't think we should try.
Do you have a third lifeline pack?
You call it on so we can get the...
83.
Leave these guys behind us to fight.
Oh, they're gonna fucking ult soon.
We are definitely not in zone.
Yeah, this is gonna be tough.
I know.
I have evac tower as well, but we shouldn't use it.
We can't use it.
They're directly underneath me.
I might try to go for a Mozambique on them.
They're right down here.
This is Jent.
I'll stay here and keep the fort down.
I got it.
Nice!
You got the knock?
We'll keep the fort down.
We play for... how long are we on?
Care package?
99.
It's up.
Where do you want it?
Just call it out right here for the point.
Yeah, just for the door and block.
Oh, door?
Oh shit.
That was not the ping.
Sorry.
There is literally nothing.
Our best bet is to get a Hail Mary Watsona.
We are there.
We either Valk all then pray we get it off or we run in and play for KPA.
Do we need three ults for one person?
How many ults do we have?
We already called in three lifeline packs.
Three lifeline packs.
Yay!
Come to me.
We're just going to try to rip a Valk all.
We're going to die if we walk in no matter what.
Alright.
We're going to run.
We're going to run the Valk all thing.
I'll just throw down the Wattson.
Wattson the moment I die down.
There's literally nowhere to go.
Holy fuck.
This is a little spooky.
We're just going to land late and try to third party something.
We just got to float.
Maybe go in this corner.
Go in this corner.
Alright.
Very back corner.
We're hard safe back here.
Okay.
We have to shoot the guy on the roof.
Target the guy on the roof.
I'm just going to...
This is the best I can do.
We just have to hard shoot roof no matter what.
Yeah.
I'm just...
I'm putting my agenda down.
I'm looking at the roof right now.
I'm farming them on the roof.
Drop down.
I'll cover.
Cracked them on the roof.
Knocked one.
Nice.
I'm going to play to kill it.
I got red.
Nice.
I need to sell up.
I don't have...
Knocked another one.
Nice.
My drone is up in 9 seconds.
9 seconds.
There's just one more.
Climb up to me and shoot up the knockdown shield.
There's one person behind knockdowns.
I can help.
Shoot up the knockdowns.
I got them.
Full kill.
There's one team inside.
One team inside.
We play on the high ground the entire game.
On beacon.
Free shots.
I don't have cover.
We just play the high ground.
We just play to kill them inside.
There's people inside.
I'm going to shield cell.
Are we going to be able to get another gem?
No.
36.
I don't have all the excel for this.
Oh my god.
They're getting climbed.
They have a gen in there.
You see this wall right here?
We're going to play up here as long as we can.
We might have to slide out and play that.
They're left side.
I'm looking at the story.
Stay right.
We just stay up here as long as we can.
On beacon.
I don't see.
Could be free.
It's a draw.
I don't have bats anymore.
I'm going to shield cell.
I'm going to do slow heals.
I'm going to kill him with Valkyrie.
You have to help him.
I have to shield slow heal right now.
That's fine.
It's a solo in this pill.
3 man on the right and 3 man on the left.
Oh they're...
Oh they didn't get that.
They're running.
Shoot the 3 man.
Flash.!
Flash Flash!
I have no ammo.
Flash, flash!
We are burning, burning, burning hard!
Calm down, calm down, calm down!
Shoot these guys across!
Headshot!
Flash!
50, flash!
Knocked him, knocked him!
Downed on both teams!
Do you have nades?
Nade that!
No nades, no nades, no nades!
Got knocked!
One left, one left on this!
There is only one guy on this team left!
They are right below, they are right below!
Are they resing below us?
Don't let them res below us!
I'm trying to make sure...
They are resing below us!
Try to shoot down any of them you can!
Going!
Full kill, full kill!
Nice, one team under, one team under!
Right below, right below!
It's a duo, it's a duo, it's a duo!
Flash, flash, flash, flash!
Knocked one, knocked one, knocked one!
Last kill!
Flash!
Melee, melee, melee!
Oh, just kill him, just kill him, just kill him!
Guys, no, no!
Behind, behind, behind, behind!
Oh, he is full!
Play knocked on, play knocked on!
He is just sitting behind knocked on now.
I
wanted to get the melee!
I had no more bullets!
Yeah, I ran out of ammo too.
I ran out of ammo too!
I ran out of ammo!
I had no ammo.
I had no ammo there.
I didn't know they got that Watson out.
I honestly didn't know they got that Watson out.
I had two.
I didn't know either.
When you killed that person, I was like, wait, why is that not game over?
I ran out of ammo.
I had to melee.
We all ran out of ammo.
I had no ammo.
We all had nothing.
I used the last four bullets of a longbow and hip fire.
It was bad.
That was so close.
Maybe we got enough knocks overall.
We didn't see our damage.
We had way more than 15 on you.
We got 10 kills.
We got the kills.
That's so close.
We got 10 or more kills and we got 7 or more kills.
Oh, hey!
Nice!
Wait, we actually got a lot.
Hold on.
Let's count them up.
Let's go!
We got red armor.
One, two.
We died to PvE three.
We cleared her with melee four.
Yep.
No finish.
Ten or more kills.
Five.
Don't use this for vital items.
Six.
Yeah.
Seven.
Grab cannon.
Watson, eight.
Wait, did you 360 with your nose gun?
No.
All three times.
Twelve.
We got twelve.
We had twelve?
Aw, I think someone got 14.
I think someone got 14.
No.
Oh, come on.
If I got that melee, it would have been 13.
I was so unlucky.
No, no.
We have 12.
Wait.
We got 12.
I'm pretty sure.
Someone.
I'm going to wait until someone posts it.
I don't see anything.
Team six also got 12.
That was crud.
Because this is a bastard.
Oh, you're a dead set.
Oh, I was like...
Okay, we used the bathroom.
Are there any more than we got?
We didn't do batteries.
We didn't...
Wait, did you do the Mozambique?
Yeah, I did.
Did anyone hit a big nade or what?
No.
No melee knocks.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
Oh my gosh.
We were doing so well there.
That would have been amazing.
I mean, the only other one we could have got that game would have been meleeing for the last kill.
For the last kill, which would have given us...
I mean, we tried.
We literally all had no ammo, so...
I know.
I should have just fucking punched.
Like...
I ran out of wingman ammo.
I was only Mozambique for the endgame and I just ran out.
Ugh.
We played that so well though.
Great job.
People are tallying up and I don't see anyone with 12.
The winning team only had four.
That was crud.
That was huge.
That was a bastard.
That guy should have just threw and we would have won.
I mean, Lifeline's OP.
Yeah.
Dude, I know.
The fast res.
Ugh.
Like, I might...
Yeah, I'm definitely gonna play her again just because that was huge.
I mean, unless...
Unless you think we have a better chance.
I think we played the...
I think we played the same comp.
Did we do it?
The pull was pretty good.
The only one we missed was...
The cost of gold?
Just meleeing people and stuff.
And like a sentinel kill.
But for the most part, we got almost every...
Well, winning that game wouldn't have given us any more points unless it was a melee kill.
Yeah, it would have just given us like money and the...
Yeah.
That's so close.
But so far, we have the most.
So far.
Guys, they should give us some pity points there.
I know.
We've come second for...
We've come second so much.
Like so much.
Oh my god.
If I had the ammo, I could have killed her.
It was so close.
Guys, please.
I'm gonna type out 10 gift of shit subs.
I have 10.
You let us have this.
Give us 0.5.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
There's like 8 more teams that have not put their score in.
You can't still be counting.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm like scared now.
I'm so scared.
Because like if we get this, I don't have to try anymore.
Please.
Please not be...
Please be less than 12.
Please.
Not a lot.
Thank god.
Oh, 0.
Not a lot and 0.
4.
That was actually a crucial wingman drop.
Oh my god.
This is it.
Oh, I was fragging.
I was fragging.
Guys, I'm like...
I'm like, you know, like that's like when the one two guys for serious mode there, Chad.
I...
Guys, I don't know if you guys noticed, but I went full fucking serious mode.
The moment I was like, wait, we can win this?
I got wall.
That's actually really good.
We can get all this.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
We can.
We have two people there ready.
Wait.
I think we all lit the POI.
We go back to the prowlers and we just melee the Molotov.
We're at wall and let one person die.
It'll be free.
We shouldn't even get third back there.
Oh, we're at wall.
W.
Yeah, that's good.
We get the... yeah.
Yeah, guys.
I went full fucking serious mode.
We kinda did it, guys.
Hopefully.
Well, I mean, the team that beat us was cross team and they didn't get enough.
No, they didn't.
Oh, wait, wait.
There's another person hopping in.
They might have actually, because it took so long for them to calculate.
Well, no, but we had most kills.
Nobody got the 10 kill one either.
Yeah, but then...
I mean, but Giggles is a cost of gain.
Yeah, Giggles is... she's typing.
They're calculating right now.
The late calculators might have it.
My god, this is like so fucking scary.
I know.
This is so fucking tense now.
We're waiting for like the last couple of people.
My hands are shaking so hard too.
I'm team 9.
We got out of it.
I'm team 13 with one kill.
Oh, yeah.
So what could they have done?
I need you guys to know my hands were shaking so fucking much when it was at 1v1.
I... God, if I had the ammo, I would have fucking...
It wouldn't matter though because like we wouldn't have got any points there.
But then we get to play again on the 28th.
And we get more money today.
Yeah, we can advance to the finals if we get this.
Did we get... do we get money for getting the most challenges this...
Yeah.
If most challenges is 1500 and winning the game is 1500.
So like...
Imagine if we would have had the most...
I would have won the Thanos game.
Oh my God.
That would have been so fantastic.
Actual Thanos game if we punched him up.
I know.
I was so close.
We should have just fucking aped him.
I need...
I just need a call for someone to say just fucking punch them.
That Watson was like one punch away.
We wouldn't have wanted to do this.
The... well, the Cossack.
I dropped on the Cossack.
I died to the Cossack and I thought it was...
I thought it was a 2v1 on the side.
I didn't know the Watson was...
Yeah, you said 2v1.
Oh, you didn't know the Watson was...
I already knocked...
I knocked what?
Yeah, no.
I thought it was a bad combo.
Yeah, so then I was like, oh hey, it's your guy left.
And then I knocked him when you got knocked.
And then I was like, wait, how come we didn't win?
The game wasn't over.
Where's the champion?
And then... and then He-Me died.
I was like, oh no.
Yeah, it was bad.
No.
I was hit by a long bow.
It was bad.
The Mozambique is kind of OP.
No, wait.
I heard it actually is nice now.
Like this season.
I think maybe...
Maybe we just need to be Mozangamers.
Yo, I think we did it.
Guys, no, don't give up my hopes up, guys.
Don't do this to me.
We gotta pray for the legit worst.
There's people that have not finished calculating and that's the scary part.
Gagos has four more teams left that need to submit.
Gagos did not say anything and that freaks me out.
I know.
Well, what team are they on?
At nine.
Team nine?
Yeah.
Where did they land last game?
Do we know?
Team nine got 11.
Oh my God.
Oh, okay.
The team that won got 11.
Okay.
Wait, which team was Gagos on?
Team nine.
I don't know what POI they had.
They had...
Oh no, they have Robert or not.
Oh no, team nine got seven.
She was...
Okay, yeah.
Then they're up there.
Ashy posted.
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17.
There's three more teams.
Guys, please.
Three more teams.
Quick.
Just post it.
Guys, please.
Oh no, he already posted it 10 minutes ago.
Yeah, we won.
Oh, we did.
None of us looked at the leaderboard.
He posted it.
Yeah.
No way.
He put it at TBD.
He puts TBD first.
In leaderboard.
Yeah.
Oh, did he edit it?
Yeah, yeah.
He edits it.
It's official.
Wait, Cross is a bastard.
That could have been a 3K game if Cross didn't clutch up.
Oh my God.
I know.
Okay.
Yeah.
You said he was going to get a talking two.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I'm going to go with the Wait, was Cross the Watson?
He was a Cossack.
I'm the only one saying.
Who the fuck was on the Watson?
I have no idea.
We did it, guys.
Maybe he was the Watson.
I'm not sure.
We're taking home $1,000.
Maybe $2,000 if we rate...
We don't rate the clips.
So what are finals?
Is finals the same team as you played it?
Or did they get it?
I don't know.
It's random.
I think it's a whole new game format.
I understand.
Yeah.
It's random.
Because it's like different games.
It's like game modes from all three tournaments combined together.
And it's random.
The other ones seem too free to play.
And this one seems like the hardest one.
It's like actually still Cobb Apex.
Like the other two tournaments, it's like mini game, like hide and seek and stuff like that.
Well, Thursday is actual games though.
Because there's duos, team deathmatch, and control points.
Okay.
So that's the actual try-hards.
Those ones might be easier than these ones.
So when are the finals then?
What day is the finals?
The finals on 28th.
There's still two more.
Yeah.
There's two more weeks.
The finals itself is on the 28th.
The 14th and 21st are the invitation to the finals.
All right.
We did it.
We qualified, guys.
Now we just get to vibe.
Now we don't care.
Let's play for wins.
We can go for the win.
You can still go for most challenges.
The team got game two and three and they counted them for both.
So we can still play for...
It depends which one's easier.
We either play for the win for 1500 or we play for most challenges for 1500.
I think the challenges is easier.
Yeah.
The challenges are easier.
Okay.
If the win comes, it comes.
Yeah.
Let's just do the same thing.
Let's just go for most challenges again.
Perfect.
We have a good game then Deb.
Yeah.
Got OCAT out.
My mic is muted.
My push-talk doesn't work.
My discard just break.
We did it.
We got one win.
That was my only goal.
You have to drop us.
Mikey, please.
Oh, shit.
My keyboard doesn't work.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Okay.
Never mind.
Are you lying to me?
No.
I don't believe you.
I thought pro players have like four...
I'm good.
It's good.
Oh, just stretch.
Just stretch.
It's okay.
That's all right.
We can just run to it.
Just stretch it.
There's no way.
We could take the grab can.
Oh.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll pretend I crashed my game.
I might have to take this gravity cannon, no lie.
Okay, I'm like... No, no, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
We'll stretch, we'll stretch.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, now I... You can stretch.
You can stretch.
Okay, now I guess I'll stretch too.
I'm so sorry, guys.
I thought it was just... I am not...
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
We loot the... We loot the P.O.I.
and then we loot back to the prowlers when we do PvE.
I just want you to know I have not fucking stretched in a long time.
Yay.
You should do that, you know.
Sitting at a computer all day is bad for you.
No, that's it.
I'll just die young.
No.
But not too young.
Not too young.
I'm rehabilitated.
I go therapy now.
If we get a good zone, we might just play for Godspot and play for the WEN.
Because they're both even at this point.
Oh, we got a good zone.
You should go hit Beacon.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got too excited, guys.
I'll go hit the Beacon.
I think it's Sentinel.
I'm gonna go for the Sentinel knock.
I got a Mosi.
I'm gonna steal your loot.
We can loot through the bunker on the way if it's pulling well.
Wait, was... was the P20...
P20.
P20 knock, Mosi.
I'm knocked.
Okay, I got a P20.
I got this.
You can be free, He-me-one.
You wanna stick 48 for that Sentinel?
We can be free now.
It has to be Ironside, I think.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Yay!
Nice!
I think we just play our game still.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't think we'll get Godspot this game.
I got a bat.
Wait, where do I loot?
We go... we can go loot the bunker.
You guys loot everything.
One person's supposed to get the bunker, but...
Yeah, I guess I'll go to the bunker.
There's no more loot here.
I'll grab this, too.
Ping me a Mosi.
Unless you have one already.
I have a Mosi.
I only have a P20.
I have a Thermite, too.
Should I just come on and do it?
Oh, yeah.
We can do that.
We should do that right now.
You should do the one-person thing.
I'm grabbing this Evo Harvester quick, yeah.
Okay.
We do need to be careful.
The Zeus Station team is gonna be...
They're gonna come down.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
I'm ready.
I'm good.
Oh, I actually think we might just go to zone here.
I think it's just gonna be pulling down here.
Oh, here's a Mosi.
I have one.
Let's go loot down to the tunnel and go to zone.
All right.
Oh, wait.
The heart.
I just told you we're not doing tunnels.
You can do the heart right now while you're waiting for us.
Yeah.
No, I don't think so.
All right.
I don't have a long range.
Can we do the Thermite one real quick here?
Yeah, we can do it inside.
All right.
While you do that, I'll make the heart then.
I'm gonna go scout spot.
Just be careful.
This team doesn't want to walk up behind.
Here, Senox, you do it.
Wait, I'll do it.
I'll do it.
I'll do it here.
I have one too.
I'll do it.
You can just res me and Senox can scout.
All right.
Yeah, I wanna go scout spot.
Yeah, let him scout.
You have a Mosi, right?
I don't need to pick one up.
Yeah, I have one.
You're good.
Okay, perfect.
All right.
We got the Thermite.
I have shoots.
Shoots.
We're fighting up here.
We might third this.
Okay, I need to heal though.
Give me a sec.
Yeah, you're good.
Can Mosi take the disruptors or the hammers?
Just hammers.
Okay, okay.
All right, let me see if I can...
I got the heart.
Heart, heart, heart.
Heart's done.
Beautiful.
Coming over.
I'm gonna come up and scout the booster.
No third on that party?
No, they're not fighting.
They're not fighting.
All right.
Where do we chill?
I'm gonna hit the booster.
Let me see if it's safe.
Okay, we'll just wait then.
You're good.
You can take it.
All right, we can take it back.
All of us too.
So, you mean I will take it back and forth?
Only one of us.
Okay, one...
I'll take it back.
That was one, two, three.
Let's just all take it together.
Let's all take it together and come back.
Just pray there's nobody capping this and then we go for a spot.
Are we doing these prowlers here or no?
No, it depends.
We're gonna rip a valkal.
Then if Godspot's open, we're gonna go to zone.
If not, we can do prowlers.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay, just land on me and we're gonna valkal.
How many bats do you guys have?
I have three.
I have two.
I have zero.
I'll just drop you one just anyways.
Here.
Just hold it for now.
Oh.
All right, valkal.
All right.
Number one.
We want this.
We want this or the back building.
Look at both of them.
All right.
Okay.
I'm gonna go.
Can we do the lifeline package yet or no?
No.
I popped the ulti-excel but it wasn't up.
Is anybody over here?
To our right.
Nobody there.
We're going for this.
There's a harvester.
Is that a harvester?
Yeah.
Just keep moving forward because this team might die because I want to get this cluster of buildings if we can.
Okay.
It's either gonna end on us or those buildings.
I'm here.
This got looted.
Does someone grab this?
Yeah, I'll grab it.
I'll grab it.
There's people on the animal.
I don't know what it's called.
The monster.
Are we on these buildings?
Down B.
No, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's.
There's a team there.
Okay.
Somebody on the...
Flush.
I don't have...
Let's set up fences and we're gonna hold all this.
This bunker and that bunker.
All right.
Let's set up behind us and make sure nobody pushes us.
Okay.
I'm setting up.
Anyone fast?
Want me to set up...
How do you want me to set up fences here?
You just spam them so people know we're here.
It doesn't have to be anything crazy.
We're here.
This one fence so you know.
Okay.
We're here.
If we start getting shot in the back and we can't hold this, we just slide down and put the bunker.
Okay.
Yeah.
Don't come over here.
You could, you could call in your pack now, by the way, if you want.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course.
And Jen as well.
We're in...
I wanna put more fences here.
You can Jen in the middle of nowhere.
In the bunker probably.
Whoa.
Chill.
Hit your shots first, man.
You have a gold mag on the sniper.
So wait, let me open up the thing really quick.
Is it a no scope?
Knock with sentinel.
No scope.
I'm looking at an old one.
Does anyone have it open or should I tap out and go get it?
I have it open.
Is it...
What is it?
It's a no scope with sentinel and a...
No scope irons.
Yeah.
Sentinel knock.
It can be charged up though.
And a 360.
And a 360 no scope with sniper.
I'll play for those.
I'll play for those, I guess.
Oh, you're nuts.
All right.
Let's see.
Can you Jen just in this trench right here?
Yeah.
Just like right here?
All right.
Yeah.
So, if someone catches us, be careful.
If you hear a valk ult, they might oob on top of us.
So, we just gotta be careful for that.
All right.
That's fine.
Don't worry.
I have fences here.
It looks dangerous.
I know it doesn't matter now, but I want you guys to know we actually had 13.
Whoa.
Wait.
How did we get 13?
Because we got seven or more kills as a team and we got 10 or more kills as a team.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Nice.
So, we could have been like, no, no, no.
We got 13.
Yeah.
I just realized.
There's a small chance this pulls back the checkpoint, honestly.
Hopefully it does.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
You know what?
It's not looking good.
That's good for overall.
What if it's like down here?
Most challenges.
That's good for us.
Oh, yeah.
True.
Is that a prize?
Yeah.
Most challenges completed per team.
How many bats do you have?
I have two plus a Phoenix kit.
I was gonna give you one.
That's not.
Yeah.
Let me get one.
I'm good.
I'm dokey.
Should I just rip mine?
Whoa.
I'm getting shot at.
Wait.
Just the person across.
Do you have poke to get the purple or no?
For lifeline packs?
No, I have a flat line.
But I can try.
Okay.
That's fine.
We play.
I don't want any waste suck.
I'm gonna use my gen.
I don't have any poke at all.
Is Sentinel here for more ammo?
There's a blue bolt on this if you sell the mozone.
I got one on my.
Thank you.
This guy is very cringe.
This guy.
Actually, get a hobby.
You know what?
Come on.
Who's docking from a mozone?
I'm gonna go get some over here.
The North pad.
Could you put just a couple fences down on like our roof so people see them?
Oh, yeah.
So they're not blind.
I'm gonna take these fences away and then I'll put on the roof.
We're playing just for the win this game.
I don't think we've done enough to get the overall challenges.
Yeah, we don't.
We need...
I need two more care packs to consider it.
Three ults.
Two more packs.
I could just revoke alt and count this too.
You could.
I'm just gonna do...
I'm literally just gonna revoke alt and come back down.
I wish we could do the PVs.
Yeah, I don't think we can at this point.
I don't think we can.
Yeah.
We probably could have done...
We definitely could have done the other one.
I honestly assumed someone would take zone to be honest, but...
Arc star.
Arc star on the car.
No.
Get ready for them to land on our roof.
They just popped the...
Okay.
Just look up.
We have a team rotating towards us.
I'm coming over.
I'm gonna look above us.
We're good.
They're not gonna stun us yet.
70.
Hold on.
I'm gonna look above us.
I'm here.
They won't.
My fences are scary.
They might just hold this.
They might just hold that bunker there.
They won't.
My fences are scary.
Yeah.
I think they're just in there.
Turtling.
Arc one right here.
Okay.
I'm looking.
I cannot...
I don't have any scopes or range for anything.
I might be able to get you one here.
Do you need a one or two?
I have it on a probably.
Yeah.
That would be great.
I'll need that for my P20 later too.
All right.
I'm gonna go.
Wait.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Chill.
I'm gonna charge up my armor for free.
Purple shotgun bolt.
Primo's on.
Yeah.
I got it.
I'm good.
Oh, I knocked Watson.
Right here.
Nice knock.
Focal.
Flesh.
Oh.
They...
I'm gonna walk up a little bit.
I might be able to kill...
Yeah.
Actually, no.
No.
I might die here.
Just cutting this.
Bad idea.
Too many people.
I'm gonna pop a Phoenix.
My Watson also have charge.
Yeah.
I'm gonna hop on it.
Oh.
He was so close too.
Could you drone?
Yeah.
I got you.
I think I'm gonna push.
Thank you.
Oh.
We're still in zone.
Nice.
It's probably gonna be this cluster of buildings, but if we clear our edge, we should have a free walk-in.
So we just have to win this fight on this team that pushes us on our edge.
Yeah.
I'm worried there's gonna be a team coming from behind.
We should be...
It should be pretty hard for them to push us.
This team should help us.
So we LOS left.
All right.
And we just play like the backside right here.
Wait.
They're trying to rotate.
They're swinging.
They're swinging far right.
Okay.
I think.
Are they ready?
I think I just saw something.
Whoa.
Chill.
Oh.
Please don't get a curber.
They got the care package right there.
Are you serious?
Oh, it's a curber.
They got a curber.
Jesus Christ.
No.
All right.
We just can't peek them.
Just don't peek them at all.
They're gonna launch all one of us.
I'm gonna grab this 6x scope and snipe a little.
If we end up having to fight, just fight through the right over here if you have to.
Okay?
All right.
And then worst case scenario, we slide back and we play in bunker with a gen behind the back pillar.
Got you.
Car here.
This team rotated.
Oh.
Team north 22.
That's good.
Are you close to purple or no?
They're rotating.
For lifeline?
Probably not.
I am not.
I'm not.
There's a guy.
His teammate's over there.
I don't want to just burn my ammo.
I have 167.
I don't know.
Yeah.
You're good.
You just hold it.
That's a...
No.
Wait.
Aren't you leaving?
I'm scarred.
That means that's another team over here that's rotating.
Yep.
Aw.
I can't get it.
I'm gonna get it.
Careful.
Charge sentinel behind you.
All right.
I'm going to charge my sentinel and run up and try to knock one.
This is bad.
I'm not fucking.
Are they fighting out there?
Some of me.
Yep.
Cracked one.
Over here.
There's a catalyst here.
These guys are pretty good.
If they fight, I'm going to charge my sentinel and run up and try to knock one with iron sight.
Is anybody looking at our backs?
I'm worried that...
Yeah.
That's...
You're looking back.
I'm going to look at our side then.
Oh, we got a creeper.
We got a creeper on us.
I can grab that.
I'm going to drop my sentinel.
I can refresh the wasp now.
Do you want me to refresh it or no?
Oh, yeah.
Can you get ready to look over me?
I might die going through this grab package.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm going to watch back still.
I'm going to still watch back.
Can you shoot the building to him?
We'll borrow your scope then.
Do I go with the car?
Okay, bro.
I'm looking.
He came over here to my right.
I'm going to go with the car.
They're fighting on our ass, guys.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I have to heal.
I have to heal now.
I can't.
They're kind of not on our ass, but like behind us.
Sorry.
But they are in this choke behind.
I'm dropping your scope.
We have like God spot.
We have God spot.
We just need to...
We need to just...
On this zone, we need to just kill the team behind us.
On your ping.
Did you grab your...
Wait.
Can I take your sentinel stuff?
You can take the sentinel.
I have creeper.
I'm throwing my third care pack.
Yeah, play the pack LOS, and then we just need to kill this team on the run in.
I'm swapping back to my P20 then.
Yeah.
In case they run up.
I'm going to syringe.
140 on the one side.
Oh, I broke the gen.
Look at this.
If you have your sentinel, you might be able to knock one.
I don't have my sentinel.
I can't.
Fuck.
I need to heal.
I think we finished.
Yeah.
That's okay.
We literally just have to...
They're trying to move up.
I have to...
That's a bad...
So she died.
I'm going to...
I'm going to find 140.
Okay.
I thought they were going to push up closer, so I got my P20.
That's okay.
I'm going to bring the sentinel closer to me then.
Be careful.
This left team might walk up on us while we're doing this.
Okay.
I'm just going to...
We just have to play more towards the right, and then we just have to hard farm them.
I'm just rotating my sentinel back and forth.
I'm going to play roof and try to carve one.
It's left flank caustic.
Where is the team to the left?
I think they're in the lower...
I hear them sliding here.
Yeah, they're below us.
Below us.
Right here.
Yeah, close.
I'm going to go for a carver shot.
I see them.
Right here.
We can't fight them until we know there's nobody on our right.
They're going to try to fight us though.
They are, yeah.
They have hound caustic.
They're nading.
That might be them.
I'm looking.
We're pulling to kill them.
We have to fight to kill them.
I stun two.
All right.
Caustic at 190, 190.
Get ready to walk up.
I'm going to watch them.
I'm walking, I'm walking, I'm walking.
I have my P20.
They're backing up.
They have wing on.
I have to back.
I stun one on the right.
You can play slow.
We can play a little slow still.
I'm going to play for a carver shot.
Careful, careful, Hemi.
You're really...
I'm fucked.
I'm covering, I'm covering, I'm covering for you.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, I can't hit you.
I'm going to try to cover you.
Popping a bat.
Fencing this.
I'm going to zone.
All right.
Yeah, we need to kill them for our reset.
I'm going to play left here and try to hit a carver shot.
I have one more nade.
I have one more nade that I can use.
Okay.
Try to sky nade them.
I'm going to swing left here and try to carver one.
Okay.
I'm waiting for a scan.
They're going to push.
Okay, I'm ulting.
I'm ulting.
I'm hard walking up.
Hard walking up.
I'm waiting for a...
I'm 140.
No.
That's a good.
Got one.
I'm climbing on me.
Climbing, climbing.
On me.
Where?
On me, on me, on me.
I'm just out.
Just out right here.
No.
That's bad.
Yeah.
Good try.
That wingman is so...
Yeah, he had the wingman.
Yeah.
That wingman helped.
It's okay.
We thirsted their second.
We thirsted.
GG.
We made finals.
It's okay.
That's all that matters.
What's our count for this one?
I don't even think it matters.
Not enough.
Yeah.
I don't think it matters.
We counted for the overall.
You want to count?
Yeah.
We should count it for the overall.
Overall.
It's fine.
We got the...
Actually, it sucks.
I had shot this guy, but he had purple helmet, so he didn't die.
We did the knock with the thermal.
We didn't do any PVs though.
No.
We did not.
We were just playing for the...
We did the gravity cannon.
We did the heart.
One, two, three, four.
Yeah.
The heart.
That's it.
That's actually it.
Oh, and my ult four times.
Five.
No survival items.
Yeah.
I counted that.
Wait.
What?
What did you count before?
It was knock with the thermite, don't use survival, gravity cannon, Watson heart, and use the ult three times.
That's four?
Five?
And that is all.
That's five.
Five?
You know, five is great.
Good effort.
Wait.
Did you get the P20 knock or sentinel knock?
No.
I got it with the prowler.
Yeah.
I didn't get it.
I got it with the prowler.
Yay.
We made it to finals.
We did.
Good job.
All right, y'all.
That's it, right?
That's the last game?
Yeah.
That was the last game.
Oh my God.
This has been almost like four hours.
This was long.
For six hands, it was long.
To be fair.
I mean, imagine if we could have walked up on this nonsense.
This would have been free.
I don't know.
They're dying right now.
I know, but we would have been able to walk up.
So, would have had Wingman, Kraber.
They're actually deleted.
We would have had triple care package.
That's true.
Oh, wait.
They get free raise.
No.
Someone push him.
Oh, that Kraber hit.
Yes.
Come on.
He's literally one hit.
It's so close.
Wait.
Why am I looking?
Oh my God.
He's going to win it.
He's going to win?
That's insane.
That was crazy.
That was insane game from them.
Wait, can we see the standings?
There's no standings.
It's like a game each.
Each game is its own thing.
Yeah.
There isn't any overall standings.
There's going to be...
The only overall thing will be two most kills overall.
Yeah.
I don't think that's any of them.
That's on the controller, please.
It's legit impossible.
I mean, okay.
This is rigged.
Each team should have one controller playing.
Oh, no.
That was fun.
GG's.
We made it to the finals.
That's all that matters.
I know.
I'm so proud of us.
Oh my God.
We almost got like a champion and finals.
That would've been sick.
That would've been so fucking sick.
So we're not allowed to play the other ones, right?
No.
I think we are.
I think we get invited.
I don't know why not.
Yeah.
They might not just invite because we already made finals.
That's true.
They want to give everyone a chance at finals.
I think we are.
I guess so.
Yeah.
We gotta play on an alt or something.
But is that fair?
The other tournaments sound so fun.
There's the one that was the... what's it?
The Watson Punch-Up.
And then the Trio No Weapons.
That sounds so fucking fun.
I agree.
Yeah.
We actually got the hard one.
We got the hard one.
You actually have to like try it.
I thought the first one was the easiest.
That's why I signed up for it.
We're going to be watching the next week and they're just going to be playing hide and seek, like hiding in bushes and stuff.
I'm so sad.
I was like, oh man, this first one with the mini games, that one has to be the hide and seek one.
I was wrong.
I was so wrong.
We did great though.
Proud of us.
We did great.
Yeah.
GG's guys.
GG's everybody.
It was great meeting all of you guys.
Yeah.
You too.
GG's.
Bye bye guys.
Bye.
Peace.
Oh my God.
We did it guys.
We got to the finals.
Easy thousand dollars.
Winner of the finals.
The finals are March 28th.
So just look forward to that.
I don't know if I can actually participate in the other ones.
I wish I could participate in the other ones.
The other ones are so fun.
Like I really wanted to do the March 21st with the three strikes, no weapons and Watson punch out.
The Watson punch out is apparently like the players have to kill the Watson character on the other team via punching.
Like that sounds so fucking fun.
I'm just going to ask him.
Tempo.
Can I still do the other damage?
Even though I got into the finals.
I'm going to ask him.
Because the other ones.
Sounds so fun.
Let me in.
I got it.
Let her in.
All right.
Anyway.
They still have to apparently check the...
Um.
Let me in.
Check to make sure... Guys, do we have any cool clips?
Do we have any more cool clips?
Because they're going to be voting for clips, I think.
Guys, are there any more cool clips?
We can get like 3000!
Sorry, no.
We can 2000.
No, we can technically get 3000 if we won two of the clips.
If both of our clips are really, really good.
Okay, let's see.
Alright, no.
This is... No, not these clips.
Okay.
Why did you clip me making a heart?
Okay, no.
None of these... None of these clips are as good.
No.
Okay, we submitted three clips, guys.
When are they going to vote for the clips?
We just need to wait for them to start voting.
We just need to have the vote.
And then we're good to go.
We need the vote.
Let me in!
Okay.
So, apparently, what's left is the clip.
I don't know if I should wait until the clip...
the clip vote, or if I should...
If I should just call it.
I don't know how the clip stuff is going to work.
Like, are they doing the vote now?
Or...
Or the introvert clip is called?
Okay.
Alright, I'll post that.
No!
That's bad!
Because it's like... You see my pain of trying to fucking talk to people.
Okay, wait.
Let me in.
What the fuck?
That's just me spilling my bubble tea!
That's fucked up!
What the fuck do you mean?
It's relatable.
Okay, fine.
I'll post this.
Look, everybody else's clips... Guys!
I'll just have you know...
Everybody else's clips are like...
Gameplay.
Everyone else's clips are like...
Gameplay clips.
And then I'm just the one being like...
Look at all the shit I fucked up on.
Holy shit!
I set you apart.
Like...
What is this bullshit?
Guys!
Please!
Guys, this is not fair.
All my clips are...
Like...
Everybody else's... It's like... Look!
1v4!
Wingman clutch!
Triple sentinel knock!
1A 285 damage!
And then you guys!
Goodbye, you're dead.
Team discussing the strats.
Jokey.
Send Knox unalives himself.
Guys, what the fuck is this?
I didn't like this one.
Epic win!
Playmaker!
Final two teams!
What do you mean?
What is this bullshit?
Give me something that makes me look good.
Yeah.
I got the flavor cleveless.
You're like...
You are the content creator for a reason.
This is not fair!
Why?
I like...
Oh my god!
This one has subtitles!
Wait!
Oh my god.
This is so bullshit.
This is actually so bullshit, guys.
Why don't I get the cool clips?
We don't need to look good.
We are good.
This is bullshit!
I should have good clips!
I did so...
I was so fucking cool in some of them.
Come on.
We're helping you send out.
That is true.
But the people that are voting for this are all fucking apex watchers.
They don't give a fuck about content.
They don't...
What the fuck do you mean?
These are apex watchers!
They don't care about what's funny.
They care about what's cool.
Wait!
No!
This is so big brain.
Because all the apex watchers are going to be split vote.
They are all like so cool.
Wait, no!
You guys are actually.
You guys are actually really smart.
You guys are actually so smart.
You're splitting all the votes.
We're splitting all the votes of like all the...
All the fucking...
All the cool clips.
So then people who just want to laugh, they'll vote for me because they will laugh at me.
Not with me.
So, god.
I don't know if that's...
The thing is, I don't know if there is enough voters that will vote for that.
I don't know.
The only issue is that I don't know if we have enough voters that will vote for that though!
What if there's not enough?
Yeah, that's totally the plan.
Are they voting for the clips now?
Okay, let's see.
Alright.
Do we have anymore?
Okay, I'll send in one more funny clip.
I'll get the undecided voters.
That's where we're aiming at right now.
We are the undecided voters.
Okay.
I will send one more clip into the category.
There's so many clips.
I'm the only one that sent more than one.
I'm actually just spamming them.
I'm just spamming them shit right now.
We are in the excitement.
We are the exception here.
Alright.
Okay, what else?
What can we...
What can we send?
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
I'm trying to see.
I need to know.
Can we vote?
Okay, the voting is happening in the community's...
like, girls' Discord right now.
Uh...
So, like...
We can't vote for it because we're not in her Discord.
Send the voting...
It's happening in her Discord!
We're not gonna raid her Discord just to vote.
What is this?
Wait, drop the clip.
Is it a cool clip?
Or is it a ha-ha funny clip?
Shit!
Guys, no!
I'm good!
How are we going to...
Guys!
How are we gonna beat this?
He took the ha-ha vote!
How do we beat that?
Good!
It's over.
It's so over.
I linked it.
I fucking linked it.
This...
That one...
Yeah, that one was pretty funny!
No!
I did it.
I sent the link.
It's over.
It's so over.
We're not gonna win...
We're not gonna win the ha-ha clip now.
We're not gonna win the ha-ha clip.
It's over.
Even you guys know it's over.
You guys know it's over.
Yeah!
That was...
That's over!
Going down knowing that you tried.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Alright.
Okay, alright.
I will...
I will send one last clip, guys.
I will send one last clip.
I'll send one last clip.
Is there anything that we have?
That's good!
Do we have anything?
We tried.
It's over.
Okay, nevermind.
We all gave up.
Alright.
I'm not gonna wait until...
I'm not gonna see who got the clips that...
It's over.
Introvert clip is still fu- FINE!
I'll do the introvert- Wait, are you the one that fucking made that clip?
Is that why you keep shilling it?
No, you're not.
Okay, I'll...
Fine!
I'll send the introvert clip over.
Alright, I'm gonna call it here.
That was fun though!
Okay, for those who don't know...
Change of schedule.
I'll post this on Twitter.
And...
I'll post this on Twitter later.
But there has been a change of schedule!
Oh shit.
Okay.
So...
This is the new schedule now.
We changed it to fit people's...
Other people's schedule.
So Resident Evil 4 and Hufo-Ban...
Are both swapped now.
So...
Over here...
Tomorrow it's Hufobia.
And then for those who are like, what the fuck is Hufobia?
It's basically like...
You play as either a hunter or deers.
And then the hunter...
Has to like try to kill the deers.
And it's not just like three deers.
There's like lots of deers.
And the deers have to pretend to be deers.
And like...
Beat the shit out of the hunter.
So...
So like...
That's basically it.
So it's like deers versus hunters.
Inside you are two deers.
Yeah, I've been wanting to play that game for a while.
But I like...
There was like no multiplayer.
But then they recently added...
There was multiplayer.
But there's no private servers.
But they recently added private servers now.
So like... I'm looking forward to it.
So...
So that's Hufobia.
And then obviously Resident Evil 4...
I saw people asking if it was the original or the remake.
I will be playing the remake.
Because I don't want to restart it.
I don't want to go back from the beginning.
From the original.
I don't want to replay the original.
So we're going to be playing the remake.
So at least we can finish it this time.
So...
Anyway...
That is the current schedule.
Anyway guys!
I hope you guys had a great time.
I'm so happy we made it to the finals.
I honestly did not expect us to make it to the finals.
And...
It's hard being the extroverted introvert.
Because...
I tried my best to be social.
Amongst Apex streamers.
Because that is very difficult to do when you are the most social person.
As the introvert.
So...
I tried my best.
Anyway...
Thank you everybody for coming.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And...
You said it for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!